e
morning if you please uh join me in the
Allegiance I of the flag the United
States of America America and to the rep
for stands Nation God
all thank
you with that I open the public hearing
on House Bill
597 and invite sponsor to introduce the
bill
okay thank you Mr chairman I appreciate
the kind introduction and through you to
my esteemed colleagues of Criminal
Justice and Public Safety uh my name is
Bill Boyd I'm a state representative
representing Hillsboro T 12 the uh town
of marac and I am here to present to you
house bill
597 which provides technical
enhancements to the existing law
regarding
911 uh this bill was brought to my
attention by um
my former police chief I have a
relationship because he was I was on the
Town Council when he was police chief of
marac but Mar Doyle is now the uh
director of emergency services and
communication for the Department of
Public Safety and uh he brought these uh
language updates to my attention I was
more than happy to to bring forward to
uh begin to codify what is already in
existence what already 911 is already
doing um the um I did provide all of you
an email this morning and I provided
copies to the committee but uh in a
nutshell the proposed Bill clarifies the
language and the definition so that
existing protocols that are in place
right now are now going to be
statutorily allowed um the language
change also allows the
e911 uh the capability to continue
transferring those calls so that people
that are calling into 911 can get the
access to the right right level of care
that they need quickly um that really is
the is the Genesis of it uh director
Doyle is here today and I certainly
would defer to director Doyle and I
would amplify his testimony to you my
colleagues because he is the architect
he's worked closely um with members of
the mental health community members
within Department of Health and Human
Services um he's also worked with a with
a drafting attorney down at OLS to make
sure that the uh that the language in
this bill does indeed intend to uh
remedy uh as I said remedy the uh uh a
service that the state is already
providing so with that being said I will
answer any questions about can but
otherwise I certainly would defer to
director Doyle to get granula with any
questions you may have and thank you Mr
chairman thank you for bringing us to
bill um and I don't see any questions
we'll save them for the director okay
thank you very
chairman Roy members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Holly Stevens I'm the
director of public policy at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people affected by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to speak in support of
House Bill
597 having been established in July of
2022 the uh New Hampshire's 988 crisis
and suicide um Lifeline is still
relatively new despite the state
investing in a very successful
promotional campaign uh there are still
some individuals who have either not
heard of 988 or when in crisis still
call 911 because that is what they are
used to currently the 911 system has a
process in place to transfer Mental
Health crisis calls 2 988 centers when
it's appropriate to do so this bill
would not change that practice it would
only uh codify this practice into state
law transferring these calls to 988
makes sense for several reasons
including freeing up 911 services for
higher level physical health and Public
Safety
emergencies and also that 988 staff have
specialized training to work with people
in a psychiatric crisis over the phone
and have a close connection with
Community
Resources when individuals with mental
illness receive the right services at
the right place at the right time fewer
folks end up homeless hospitalized or
incarcerated all of which cost the state
far more than providing Community
Resources which is something that the
988 uh uh staff are able to to connect
folks with a majority of 988 calls do
not necessitate a mobile dispatch for
immediate assessment unlike 911 where
emergency services are always dispatched
many calls to 988 can be resolved over
the phone therefore money um are saved
services and money are saved when the
Mental Health crisis calls get rooted to
988 rather than being responded to by
911 Mental Health crisis needs and
deserves a mental health
response uh this goal is supported by
the current practices and should be
caught ified into law and for those
reasons Nami New Hampshire urges the
committee to vote ought to pass on House
Bill 597 I'll take any questions that
you may have thank you Mr St Could you
um could you give me an example of a of
a 988 call what one might be and how one
might be um resolved over the
phone yes um a lot of folks they might C
call in feeling um anxious or depressed
but not necessarily having um suicidal
ideation that's life-threatening um so
they might need some resources they
might need to be connected with a
therapist of their Community Mental
Health Center and those are um things
that folks can talk with them about also
too there are some times that folks are
having thoughts of suicide but don't
have a plan don't have the means um in
their access and so they might be able
to um do a safety plan with the person
to stay with family members um and then
connect them with um seeing somebody the
following day so that can happen too um
but uh when somebody when they do the
assessment and there is um a significant
of danger to the person or somebody else
they do um send out um a mobile crisis
worker to do an
assessment you further
questions um representative
Newman
yeah I just have a quick question so
if I understand this correctly 911 now
currently makes that decision if they
get a call that is not required they
send it over and they can dial on 988 so
you haven't really changed a lot you're
just codifying that is that correct
that's correct and I will actually um
let um director Doyle answer that
question I think he's more qualified to
answer that question than I am but yes
thank you representative
lels thank you for taking my question
can you tell me as far as the the 988
operation how many people are typically
Manning that uh and is that a
247 uh operation it is a 247 operation I
would have to get back to you um and
contact Caroline as well as headrest to
find out how many folks are on at any
given time but the way that the system
is designed is when the phone calls come
in they come into one of those um uh
organizations first if they're all uh
tied up with phone calls it will be
bounced to the other one and if those
folks are also tied up it will be
bounced to a uh another organization out
of state that will answer that call so
they are answered all calls are answered
despite the fact that there might be um
nobody available in the state of New
Hampshire to answer those calls so they
are answered and they are answered
within one to two minutes of the
somebody's not on hold for more than
generally like one to two minutes um I
do know that um Jenny OA Higgins from
the Department is also here that might
have more um information on the exact
data if folks wanted that information on
the rates of answering the calls but
that's something also that I could get
for you is is uh how many calls are
answered in state I think we're close to
the 90% Mark that uh samsa is asking
states to get to um that they're
answered in State versus being bound on
stat of state but all calls are answered
Muse any further questions
representative
PR so if I doubt this number does that
connect me to the crisis team because I
know I have a different number to get a
hold of the crisis team that comes out
will this do the same thing it will do
the same thing when new New Hampshire
launched its crisis um system before 988
was um in existence and then um before
there was Geo routing for phone calls um
if you had a didn't have a 603 phone
number it was bounced to and wherever
like I have a 207 it was bounced to
Maine and to avoid um people
being bounced out of state we provided
the 8 888 number to get a hold of so
that was for a local response only but
if if a 988 call comes into headrest who
does not dispatch mobile and mobile
needs to be dispatched they will do um a
call to carolon that does the uh mobile
work and we'll get that mobile uh
dispatch
going okay I think I understood
that thank you no further questions
thank you thank you the chair calls Mark
Doyle
uh push the button again red there you
go there we go thank you good morning Mr
chairman and thank you all for giving me
the opportunity to speak to you today in
support of HB
597 establishing a designated Behavioral
Health Access Point within the enhan 911
system what we're doing really is to
clarify the the current process by which
we transfer calls from 911 to uh the
rapid response access point or the 988
seide prevention and crisis lifeline and
the purpose of the proposed legislative
changes to the enhanced 911 system
include a changes under the definitions
which is directed to clarify that
language and uh allow the transfer to
the rapid response a access point so
that they are statutorily allowed
current language mentions specifically
that e911 can transfer Emer calls
directly to a public or private safety
agency and those are defined as
governmental or private entities which
provide emergency services including
police fire and emergency medical or
ambulance uh or ambulatory Services
since the onset of 988 though the
National Suicide Prevention and crisis
Lifeline e911 has worked closely with
Department of Health and Human Services
to establish a transfer protocol to the
Statewide rapid response access point
which is the 988 affiliate here in New
Hampshire this protocol has facilitated
transferring calls from the 911 Public
Safety answering point to the rapid
response access point for persons having
a mental health crisis allowing them to
get the right level of help at the right
time for their non-emergent behavioral
or mental health needs this clarifying
language codifies this Authority and
statute so e911 can connect people so
that they can again get the right level
of help at the right time without un
undo delay and again I want to thank you
all for the opportunity to speak to you
in support of this bill and hopefully we
can make sure that this is done so that
we can actually have this statutorily
authorized and move forward the folks
here that have already spoken in favor
of and in support of the bill
represented a number of constituencies
uh that we've worked very closely
together since the onset of 988 which
goes back to just about 2020 when we
started this process um and I think
we're at a very good point right now
where we're able to actually see some
success stories by which we've been able
to transfer cause to 988 to date since
January of 2020 or since January of 2022
I should say we've facilitated warm
handoffs with 988 the rapid response
access point in the state almost 500
times those are 500 calls or callers
that would have otherwise been pointed
to a law enforcement response which
isn't necessarily the right level of
help for those people in a mental health
crisis again I want to thank you and I'm
certainly available to answer any
questions that you might
have thank you
one thing I'm a little bit curious about
is is how exactly that works and for and
how you instruct
dispatchers because there are pretty
serious consequences if you refer
somebody to a suicide or or mental
Crisis Prevention Hotline who should
have been referred to law enforcement
and and vice versa so what what is in
place right now to assure
to ensure that that happens correctly
and is there anything in this in the in
the bill that that's being proposed that
will ensure that that's being done
better thank you for the question that's
a very good question and I always love
to take the opportunity to point out the
length and bread of training that our
Public Safety telecommunicators go
through when
it's when it's their responsibility to
actually handle andriage appropriate
calls emergent and non-emergent calls in
the 911 call center as you know we go
through a Litany of training scenarios
both associated with the police fire and
emergency calls as well as now with 911
or excuse me 988 and mental health
related Behavioral Health crisis calls
that training spreads across about 16
weeks of training before these folks are
uh in a position where they've been
approved to go out on their own having
said that what we had done and this is
done in concert was then in concert with
the folks from headrest with the folks
from at the time it was the uh rapid
response access point of Behavioral
Health crisis Services uh group from uh
carolon as well as our paap or Public
Safety answering Point supervisors and
chief of operations uh as well as the uh
senior staff here at 911 to make sure we
put in place a protocol that would
address those concerns exactly and we've
created in concert with emergency
medical dispatch protocols a trios chart
which gives specific Clare guidance to
our telecommunicators when they handle a
call which alludes to or is directly
requested from the caller in the sense
that they need a a 988 or rapid response
Mental Health crisis related response
and what they do is they actually go
through that triage chart to indicate or
ask questions and interview the caller
to find out if it is eligible for a warm
transfer some of those some of those
roots would show whether an individual
suggested that they were in a position
to harm themselves whether they had a
weapon whether they hadat threaten to
harm themselves whether we're actually
in a crisis where they could hurt
somebody or anyone else whether they've
done it in the past or whether they have
a plan if that's the case those calls
are routed directly to a law enforcement
response because of the emergent nature
of the associated call if not those
calls are then handed off warmly to the
988 or rapid response access point call
center so that they can actually have
that call handled by a mental health
counselor that doesn't end there though
and I'm I'm glad you brought up this
question I think clarifies how it work
works both ways in the event that that
call is transferred off and it turns
into a call that requires an emergeny
response where the mental health Council
has now determined because of things
that have been said or discussed over
the course of that discussion that
conversation that call can be
transferred back to 911 for an
appropriate emergent response and either
police fire or emergency medical or
combination of all three to respond and
handle a call in crisis mode in emergent
mode thank you you're welcome
um you've been obviously been doing this
now you're it's happening right now what
was the impetus to go ahead and put in
statute do you feel like there was some
exposure that that perhaps not having it
in statute left us open to or what was
the thank you for the question and
that's a very good question as we were
looking into what it was that we were
doing in terms of the warm uh trans
transfers and the handoffs one of the
things that we started to do as a course
of what we always do when it comes to
rul making at the department of safety
is to make sure that our rules are
appropriate for the laws that we're
currently responsible for complying with
and when we looked at the definition of
what a private safety agency was we
realized in concert with our legal
discussion and a legal team at
Department of Safety private safety
agency doesn't capture what 988 or rapid
response currently does in terms of a
non-emergent response so we needed to
make sure that we went back to the
drawing board so to speak and clarify
the language and statute so that it does
comply with what the rule making says
and then we have to hopefully that this
passes hopefully we go back to Ru making
now to make sure that that's compliant
with the statute as it has changed and
been modified so again it's just a
matter of clarifying language to codify
exactly what it is that we're doing we
think we're doing a really good job at
it right now to make sure that we're
just walking in lock step with what it
is that we're required to do from a
rulemaking perspective as well okay so
there was no no National change or
movement or anything like that no good
all right
um any yes representative
s thank you for taking my question um I
I think I have a pretty good grasp about
the 911 system but the 988 system um if
if it's a mental health situation you
transfer it to 988 does 988 ever
dispatch mental health professionals to
the
scene the answer is as my understanding
is yes they do if it warrants that type
of dispatch I would rather have me one
of my partners from Health and Human
Services speak to what that workflow
works like they have folks that can
actually respond in the field they can
set up followup appointments they can
work with the Community Mental Health
Centers of mobileal crisis response
teams to do just that and they have I'm
sure that they have some success stories
on what that looks like as
well thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank you so much I do have written
testimony that I can pass
Higgins good morning chair and members
of the committee my name is Jenny O
Higgins I'm the legislative liaison for
Behavioral Health at DHHS so we are here
today to provide some information on
House Bill 597 as you've heard already
from my colleagues we have been working
very closely on our 988 and rapid
response system so in New Hampshire
you'll probably hear a lot about if you
haven't already the DHHS road map and
our mission zero work our tenure Mental
Health Plan and children's system of
care so all of this is a part of these
goals essentially what we have learned
is that in best practices in Behavioral
Health crisis care there are three
pillars and those three pillers are
someone to talk to someone to respond
and somewhere to go and so what we're
talking about today is that first pillar
of someone to talk to it's the call
centers and some of the questions that
I've heard today are kind of about that
someone to respond piece so in New
Hampshire today we have two call centers
they answer the phone text and chat
24/7 and they operate both from the
National Suicide and crisis Lifeline
that is a network of 200 centers across
the country and they we also have a
center as you had mentioned earlier
representative that is also answers in
833 3 710 6477 phone number the purpose
as I believe you heard earlier of
standing up a separate line was to make
sure that if you had an area code from
outside New Hampshire you would always
still reach a New Hampshire Center since
standing that up the FCC has approved
Geo routing in and so we are able to um
still reach a center closest to us now
from any area code but at the time that
was not true so that's the reason for
the two phone numbers is that the longer
10 digit number you'll always get your
New Hampshire trained centers and with
988 you're you have the potential to
reach the 200 centers that are in
network there the um the additional
benefit of being a part of that 988
suicide and crisis Lifeline though is as
you heard is if if the phone line is
tied up you will bounce to one of these
other trained centers and they have the
ability to get you resources in your
state as well and as you also heard many
calls are de-escalated by phone text in
chat so it's critically important that
there is someone to talk to um when
someone needs that Crisis Care so in
that partnership and through the work
that we've been doing in New Hampshire
we have worked really closely with 911
to make sure that people are able to get
that appropriate response and um I
really just wanted to make sure to
answer any questions for you all
today thank you you you said text so
someone could text to 988 and say I need
to talk to someone and you could have a
whole conversation
absolutely and that's been critically
important especially for teens in New
Hampshire our 14 to 17y old girls in
particular who are accessing that and
they're also at an a risk of suicidal
ideation and so our data in New
Hampshire shows that that's a high-risk
group and that they're utilizing that
text modality does 911 also have that
capability we do we had the ab to
911 okay I know that we have we've got
the domestic line where where we
encourage people to text if they're in
an unsafe place so I'm wondering if all
these things are all connected um so we
have our our domestic violence hotline
we have our mental health hotline we
have our emergent care hotline um what
else is there I know there's The Runaway
Teen line is that in any way affiliated
or no so in at this time we have been
working in partnership with with many
different crisis lines in New Hampshire
prior to standing up rapid response we
had over 30 phone numbers in New
Hampshire for Behavioral Health crisis
care so while it feels confusing that we
have two national 988 and rapid response
that's actually a significant progress
in the last five years because we had
ever crisis lines for all of our regions
and and we didn't have text and chat uh
modalities so we've made really
significant progress I think it would be
likely ideal to have one three-digit
phone number like 911 I know my children
are able to really describe easily you
know when when you need police fire and
ambulance you call 911 and when you're
sad angry or overwhelmed you call 988
and have a generation growing up with
that when we know that this is Su
suicide is a leading cause of death for
young people in our state that feels
like a really critical change for New
Hampshire and the nation um so we're
moving towards a system that's going to
be better and better as we go um but
we're not necessarily fully there yet
we're in sort of our quality improvement
phase and we do still have the two phone
numbers um and we are promoting them
together in the same way so call either
we can get you the services you need if
you call 911 now we can get you to the
right level of you know service if it's
Behavioral Health if you call 988 and
it's a 911 call that's why we have this
collaboration yeah that's great okay
further questions representative
Newman could you detail a little bit if
if someone calls with a Texas area code
and then you get the call how does it do
that does it do through location on the
phone or how does that yeah so Geo uh
the Geo routing Works where they're they
ping the nearest cell tower like if
you're calling from a cell phone that's
pinging the nearest cell tower and
they're getting you a center that they
believe to be closest to you but you may
end up getting a Massachusetts Center or
something with the with the national
call center right but those 200 call
centers in that 988 suicide and crisis
Lifeline are all trained to to and they
have a resource directory online for
every state so they take the call that
they get if the caller is calling you
know from Texas and New Hampshire
answers they try to connect them to that
care in Texas and they do have that
resour that online resource directory um
but they don't they're not going to
transfer a caller who's in crisis
because there's a risk of losing the
call and so you take the call you get
and some and the there has been that
improvement with Geo routing whereas a
year ago you were only routed by your
area code so again we're sort of in this
we're kind of in the mud right now of
making improvements to a system that's
newer so we it would be ideal if it just
already worked like 911 but there was a
time where none of us had heard of that
either right so it is just a a newer
system follow follow
up so um there there's nothing right now
that recognizes the location of the
phone from geolocation to to send the
call to the right place is that correct
I'm sorry it works as Geo routing which
pings the nearest cell tower geolocation
is there's such a Nuance here in those
two terms but 911 is approved for
geolocation where they can actually know
where the caller is located and for 988
it is to try to get you to your nearest
Center and some of the reason for that
Nuance at the federal level and the FCC
approval was that there were Advocates
who really wanted um people in suicidal
crisis to be able to remain somewhat
anonymous and so they didn't want the
location pieces um of course if there's
a crisis that where it is a rescue line
and if there's a crisis that needed a
911 uh we could transfer to them and
they would be able to utilize the
geolocation pieces of that um nationally
the data shows that less than 2% of call
text chats to 988 need any kind of
emergency response like that they really
need the someone to talk to thank you
representative lels
you may have just answered my question
but my question relates to a 988 call
that that is does not require 911
response but needs somebody on the scene
um how does that handled yes so those
three pillars of Crisis Care again are
the someone to talk to and then someone
to respond and someone somewhere to go
so those are like our easiest ways of
describing what is obviously a comp
system but what we have in New Hampshire
today is two call centers that can do
the someone to talk to we have 10 mobile
crisis teams operated through our
community mental health centers and
those mobile crisis teams can respond in
community again we're in the kind of
Workforce buildup and quality
improvement stages of that so ideally
they would be able to respond in
community 247 when that was necessary um
today that looks different depending on
the region and and the hiring rates and
all of that within the that place but
they do have access to tella Health in
that way too for a CL a mental health
clinician to connect with someone and so
the 10 Community Mental Health Centers
are working through all of those issues
today and are able to respond in
community quite often it's about a
quarter of calls that end up getting a
mobile crisis response so 75% of calls
is I could get you exact data in email
if you want it but I'm just saying it
off the top of my head but um about 75%
of our calls in New Hampshire are are
de-escalated by phone and those that
need an in-person mental health response
that other quarter of um call calls are
able to get connected to those mobile
crisis teams and then we're piloting two
crisis stabilization centers in Dover
and lonia Dover is open and lonia is
soon to be open and that's that third
pillar so that's sort of where we're at
in the middle of building a Behavioral
Health crisis system in New Hampshire
followup Mr chairman follow up what sort
of cover do you have for Coos County uh
so the mental health center there has a
mobile crisis team and I would have to
go back to ask their Staffing ratio
today I know that that's that's
obviously a place where there has been
Workforce challenges across the board
not just in Behavioral Health but they
do have a mobile crisis team I would
just have to ask them how their Staffing
was going do you know where they're
based I could get back too on it I'm so
sorry okay thank you representative new
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
for taking my question um I think it's
in line with what representative lales
was saying um but a little bit deeper in
um I've had the pleasure of getting to
know the the mobile crisis team in the
mannok region um out of Manu uh family
services and so my what I hope would or
think would be clarifying is to explain
what it looks like what a mobile crisis
unit actually shows up uh goes out um uh
and what that looks like when they
respond as opposed to um especially as
opposed to you know when if police
showed up or you know what I mean what
what exactly would that look like yeah
so what we we have a couple of different
types of sort of certifications we have
a crisis certification we have and then
we have clinicians that can be a part of
that team and then we have peers that
can be a part of that team so peer
support services is someone who has
experienced a mental health um condition
of their own and so they're able to and
they have you know training and can
offer recovery supports and so typically
a clinician or a crisis trained
counselor and a peer go out as a team
and they can sit with that individual
and um you know be in that space with
them and have that kind of training
that's specific to mental health it can
sometimes be really intimidating to have
you know folks in a uniform with a badge
kind of show up when you're in a mental
health crisis there's such a critical
need for all of our First Responders
this is kind of a fourth first responder
right we've got police fire and
ambulance and then we've got mental
health uh crisis counselors that can sit
with you in that time of need and be
able to have that specialty training and
we recognize that they there's not the
medical piece of having you know an EMT
on the scene and we that's why the
partnership or the we not the law
enforcement you know it's the it's that
we all can partner to get the right
response when it's needed so if someone
is at in imminent risk and or if if
there's homicidal or suicidal idation
and the person is um has means and it
you know there's an at risk we're going
to partner with those with our other
three First Responders right we're going
to send police fire and ambulance to a
life saving situation but when we know
that 75% of these calls are de-escalated
by phone and then we can connect people
to same day next day appointments or to
ongoing Mental Health Care um that's
life-saving too it looks different right
than the way that we could see saving a
life when um there's a someone has a
heart attack right but but it is it's
Having the courage and the language to
sit with someone in crisis that can save
their life and can I ask one quick
followup so out of the uh mental health
our our Regional Mental Health um um
community centers how many are kind of
at the level that that is possible I I
know you were saying they're in various
stages and and I acknowledge that manok
is probably at a different stage and Le
the other ones I'm just yeah so I I
absolutely know that my director of the
mental health Bureau would be able to
answer you on the spot about the
Staffing of each of those teams I just
don't have that information so I'm happy
to email it to the committee but we had
you know in conquered Manchester and
NASA these teams have been operational
for longer in the in those cities and so
they are up you know up and running and
responding to many many calls and in
some of the regions especially that are
more rural like I was saying earlier
there's Workforce challenges in every
sector and and Behavioral Health is no
exception and so there are times where
those teams may not be fully staffed
they do always still have access to the
telea health and then we are working you
know very part of standing up a crisis
counselor certification is to actually
make sure that we can expand that
Workforce and um we're also looking at
all kinds of creative and alternative
methods and I really think about it a
lot as how you know Manchester has 200
firefighters but a rural region is going
to have a volunteer apartment and so we
need to get creative and um and
sometimes it can be just being able to
sit with someone in crisis and talk with
them and so there are probably a lot of
different ways that New Hampshire can
figure out how to respond to this as
long as you've got some training right
and so that's there's so many different
ways that we're working towards how do
we build this Workforce so that we can
save the lives of our friends and
neighbors um and I think New Hampshire
is so good at that so sorry I'm so wordy
it's okay you thank you for uh talking
to us this morning absolutely is there
anyone else wishing to testify in this
spill who has not done so seeing none I
right
e
I hereby open the public hearing on
hospit 602 and invite representative
bill good morning chairman Roy honorable
members of the committee for the record
I'm representative Nancy Murphy
currently serving my third term
representing the town of marac Hillsboro
12 I come before you this morning to
introduce HB 602 relative to proposed
Public Safety legislation that would add
a requirement for completion of an
online Victim Impact Panel program to
meet court ordered obligations for DUI
impaired driving
offenses I don't think single a single
one of us is unaware of the challenges
our law enforcement officers are facing
as they try to address the very real and
very problematic issue of impaired
driving in New
Hampshire we can't turn on the news
without learning of another accident or
fatality with impaired drivers often
behind the wheel or pick up a
newspaper a deadly year on the road
safety officials seek new ways to stop
dangerous driving protecting impair
drivers from themselves while at the
same time protecting the public at large
from becoming innocent victims must feel
like an ex an exercise and futility some
days for law enforcement HB 602 would
provide an additional
program tool for New Hampshire law
enforcement and the court to address duy
related offenses decrease offender
recidivism and save lives the impetus
for this bill came by way of a telephone
call from my local police chief Brian
Lake not as a request for legislation
but rather to share information and his
own experience with what I've heard for
the first time described as an online
Victim Impact penel program for DUI
impaired
drivers Chef Chief L was uh in uced to
this
technology um by his predecessor our
former police chief Denise
Roy given their vastly Superior
knowledge of all things law enforcement
DUI and Victim Impact Panel program in
general both Chief Lake and former Chief
Roy are here today to testify as well if
you look at the bill you will see that
HB 602 would require DUI offenders to
compete complete the online Victim
Impact Panel program this phrase is
defined and described
within the bill using you impact an
online Victim Impact Panel program that
already exists and is currently serving
DUI Justice involved individuals across
the United States and even here in
multiple New Hampshire towns it's the
gold standard program model Chief Roy is
an excellent resource for specific
information about the U IMPACT program
and current New Hampshire participation
I want to be clear um as you will note
there is nothing in this bill that
references you impact act or any other
program by name rather should HB 602 be
considered favorably by the committee
any program that could meet the
requirements included within the
definition of a qualified online Victim
Impact Panel program would be eligible
to provide these services in addition to
those testifying today I'd like to thank
the department of safety's assistant
commissioner DMV director liquor
commissioner and members of The
Association of chiefs of police um
Sheriff Association State Police
judicial branch uh AAA and Association
of
counties um with for all who had met
with me and provided input to improve
this bill leading to the proposed
amendment that I've already handed out
um those were some suggestions that um
and uh certain phraseology that uh was
felt to improve it um I believe it's
time to put another tool in our Public
Safety toolbox and if we have the
ability to positively impact outcomes
for both DUI offenders and potential
victims and this comes at no cost to the
state or County I hope you'll agree that
we should at least be willing to try I'm
happy to take questions but as the
Chiefs will be speaking as well not the
ones whose hopes were dashed by the
Eagles on Sunday uh it may make sense to
see if they're answered during their
testimony I ask that you please support
HB 602 and send it to the floor with an
thank you um there's no charge to the
state or county is there a charge to the
offender there's a $100 charge to the
offender and if they're declared
determined to be Indigent by the court
the um right now the program that is
available you impact uh will absorb that
cost so it remains available to to the
to the uh to the individual okay thank
you see enough further questions thank
you thank you Denise Roy the chair calls
know um I want to good morning everyone
and I want to thank you for um allowing
me to be here today to discuss the
proposed Bill and that could help save
lives in New Hampshire uh a special
thank you to representative Murphy uh
for recognizing that we can do more to
reduce the rate of re ISM of impaired
drivers in our state my name is Denise
uh again last name Roy I a New Hampshire
native who grew up in Nashua for over 30
years I devoted my career though it felt
hardly felt like a work day when you
love what you do um to serving the
citizens of marac as a police officer uh
I retired in 2000 as the chief of police
during my time in law enforcement I
witnessed both the incredible resilience
of humanity and the devastating impacts
of
tragedy While most of my experiences
were rewarding none haunts me more than
those related to impaired driving for
those of you on the committee who have
similar experiences you know that
informing a parent family member or
friend that their loved one has been
killed by a drunk driver is a burden
that stays with you forever what makes
it worse is that these tragedies are
entirely
preventable in New Hampshire we see
around 5,000 driving while intoxicated
AR rest each year this number only
reflects those that have been caught we
know the actual number of impaired
drivers is much higher as a police
officer it was frustrating to see that
after a person is arrested for impaired
driving and leaves the police station
they're often just
forgotten while various resources are
dedicated to prevention and enforcement
there is much more that can be done post
arrest the purpose of my presence here
today is to emphasize that we can take
additional steps across the country many
states require individuals facing
impaired driving charges to attend a
Victim Impact Panel unfortunately these
types of panels are not widely known or
utilized in New Hampshire or New England
in
general our traditional Victim Impact
Panel consists of two to three speakers
that have been affected by impaired
driving they share stories about their
loved ones and their personal
experiences with these
tragedies I've attended and participated
in Victim Impact panels to gain a better
understanding of what an effective
program looks like although my
attendance was not mandatory I still had
an emotional response to what I
experienced I Now understand how a
program like these can reveal the Ripple
effects of one's actions an effective
Victim Impact Panel should aim to
influence participants on an emotional
level changing their attitudes towards
impaired driving and reducing likelihood
of defending importantly these panels
should not be designed to shame judge or
lecture instead they should help impair
drivers understand the ripple effect of
their choices and encourage behavioral
change participants in panels
participation in panels is crucial if
individuals are only forced to sit and
listen they are likely to disengage
encouraging involvement through
questions answers and self-reflection
fosters a better understanding of the
consequence of their
actions
moreover it is essential that these
panels feature speakers with diverse
experiences related to impaired driving
individuals involved in the justice
system may not connect with the victim's
story uh but they may find themselves in
hearing from someone who has faced
similar struggles programs with varied
speakers can be more relatable to
impaired drivers ultimately the choice
to drive impaired is just that a choice
when individuals are led to place of
acceptance and resp responsibility they
can make safer choices for themselves
creating a positive ripple effect that
extends beyond what they might see
mandating attendance at a Victim Impact
Panel can make a significant difference
in reducing the recidivism rate in New
Hampshire the cost of the state is zero
our commitment to the citizens of this
great state is invaluable how can we
Overlook such an essential tool that
before thank you Chief can you tell tell
me um where else this program is in use
that you've seen it and what your
thoughts are after having observed
it so the first part of the question is
it's in use in um it's being utilized in
every state in the country some states
utilize it more than other states uh
depending upon the um the the law that's
currently in effect uh so two of the
larger states that utilize specifically
the program that um I advocate for um
are Florida and Texas and they're um
used entirely in the State um but like I
said it's it's utilized throughout every
single state um and and I have to um I
attended both a live Impact Panel
because those um pre-co were very
popular and that's what everybody did um
this the program I advicate for uh was
developed in 2011 um so I took the
online program first but to make sure I
understood what I was advocating for I
wanted to go to a live Impact Panel um
they're completely different the
atmosphere on an online panel is
although you're some people think you
don't want the defendant to feel
comfortable but you do because that's
how they're going to understand and
that's how they're going to to interact
and when I took the course I found
myself um thinking 30 years in law
enforcement there's no way that I'm
going to feel emotional after seeing and
doing what I've done but I was sitting
at my kitchen counter and I was crying
because I was like this is truly people
don't understand that ripple effect that
their decisions have on others
um so it was much the the online online
was much it allowed me to feel that as
opposed to the live panel um I was in a
room with over a hundred people I felt
shame and I wasn't even there I was it
wasn't mandatory for me there I felt
shame uh and it just you know it wasn't
the atmosphere for me to makes you more
guarded yes absolutely guarded I didn't
know who I was sitting next to nobody
you know people were being kicked out
people were talking there were two
speakers and they had horrific stories
they've lost loved ones there's no you
can't you know you you have empathy for
that but you're not absorbing what you
should be absorbing in a Victim Impact
Panel thank you the the second part of
the question was so Florida and Texas um
have they had demonstrable drops in
their
reivisa or is there any way to tie that
to this no there there absolutely is um
the company the organization you impact
that I work for who actually uh I have
the person who has all the answers but I
do know this one um so there was a a
recidivism study done and there was
Nationwide through um the Transportation
safety agency and at the time of the
study the national recidivism rate was
25% um the recidivism study done just by
you impact on um two counties in Florida
Miami Dade County which is one of the
largest counties and Duval County um it
was the the recidivism rate was 3.9 in
Miami Dade and 2.9 in Duval County so
that's a significant drop and um and
again that's only those people who
participated in the U IMPACT Program um
there certainly are studies you know
that that question um the effectiveness
of them however the people and and we've
seen I have testimonials of people who
have actually taken the course in New
Hampshire I have worked with a couple of
the prosecutors for cases that were
pledged from DWI um and they have taken
the course and I do believe you have um
that in your packet um the testimonials
of the people who have it it actually
works CU they understand what the ripple
effect is from what they've
done final question for me is this
program mandatory in Texas in
Florida yes okay thank you um
representable
sales thank you for taking my question
uh those recid recidivis rates uh that
that that's tremendous when you talk
about impaired driving
um are you just looking at alcohol or
are there other uh forms of abuse well
the drug drug driving is obviously um a
new it's newer into the driving well
impaired um realm uh so are the are the
you IMPACT Program um does just deal
right now with alcohol related drunk
driving um but obviously with changing
of laws you have to consider changing
also the stories um to include drugged
driving as well followup Mr chairman
follow um I'm just wondering uh
distracted driving is really in a crisis
level here in New Hampshire does this
program cover that at
all well I would say yes it could but
the only um caveat to that would
be the the stories of the real life
victim and defendant that you hear in
our all are surrounded by alcohol
impairment however that being said
anytime it is also a form of distracted
driving um so anytime that you can make
somebody feel and understand um why
their behaviors should change then it to
me it's it's just as effective again I
attended both of these not because it
was mandatory but because I wanted to
experience it and it was life-changing
for me and I I'm not even you know this
it's not something that I had to do one
um where I live we have a front porch
we're able to look down on a state
highway where the speed limit is 40
miles hour and it's amazing how many of
the people that are going by that are
looking on their cell phones and it's
particularly bad among young females
that they seem to constantly be on their
their phones I'm just wondering do you
have any Outreach into the school system
the driver's head programs and so
forth so the U IMPACT Program
specifically um has what we call a Pay
It Forward program and the participants
um the people who who have to take the
course it's mandatory for them to take
the course um are are granted access to
this onehour pay it for program although
it it concentrates on um alcohol
impairment um it can also be used for
distracted driving situations um it's a
free program that um we provide to
anyone who wants it it's it's kind of
the impact's way of of trying to do
something preventative instead of being
reactionary um so that is a program that
that is used in some facilities
especially um Juvenile Detention
facilities uh specifically in California
they utilize our program um in one
specific County for for those types of
situations representative BRS thank you
Mr chairman um I'm just I I have a
question
about the cost in the mention of you
know if the person is found Indigent
that they don't have to pay however if a
person does have the ability to pay that
then they do so I'm trying to figure out
is it right to make a person pay for it
but then not to make an another would it
just not be better to just if the
program is going to be free for some
people just to be free for
all well no I no I do disagree with that
part of it um I do think you know the
the programming cost um is I'm trying to
think my colleague might be a better
person to answer this question um the
indigency is to like if a person is
charged if a defendant goes to court and
they would like a public defender um
those are the the types of case Indigent
cases that are also
um that that that the courts would give
us they would say this person's been
indent through the paperwork that they
do so it's similar to any other program
or any other sentence that somebody has
um that the the program is there's a fee
to it um you know there's no way to get
around that unless unless the state were
going to um you know pay out a
predetermined amount I mean that it's a
Diamond hello and thank you for allowing
me the opportunity to speak um my name
is terara I'm also an employee of U
impact um I came to this company with 15
years of experience as a teacher
um I'd like to speak from our Founder's
point of view our founder um passed away
so she's unable to be here um she was a
mother walking her child over a bridge
on New Year's Day and a repeated drunk
driver
swerved hit her stroller killing her
child and severely injuring her other
2-year-old
son she was a mother who
took that
angry allowing it to eat away at her she
shared her story she spoke live all
across the State of
Florida about once a month and she over
time became to realize that this was the
hardest thing she ever had to do was to
Speak Life to people to relive the worst
experience of her life and so at the
suggestion of a couple probation
officers who knew her well enough to say
we want to share your story but we just
don't want to ask you to speak again she
developed the U IMPACT
program she knew the other speakers um
Anna was best known for her storytelling
if you ever want to access the program
we always can give you access and you'll
see what a wonderful speaker she was she
was
non-judgmental she understood that if
people are sitting in a place of fear
and anger they'll never listen to your
message they need to feel safe and they
need to understand that they have the
ability to make better choices moving
forward as a company we that's what we
believe in everybody deserves the chance
to do better when they know better
they'll do better we've had close to
55,000 people across the country take
this program um one of my jobs is I
quickly read all the letters as they
come in at the end of the program we ask
people to write to
themselves saying what they want to do
better moving forward how they can do
better moving forward um consistently
people will say I didn't realize my
choice could affect somebody
else and I mean as we're all sitting
here it's safe to say we've made good
decisions in our life we've had people
who have encouraged us to make great
choices a lot of people don't have that
so of those 55,000 people the common
message is I didn't understand that the
choice to drive drunk was going to
impact everybody and so generally what
we want people to realize is that they
need to forgive themselves they need to
make a better choice moving forward
whether that's common sense for us but
not everybody having an Uber a
designated driver drinking at home not
drinking we just we want people to
realize that impair driving is a choice
and so that's how we model our
business thank you welcome represent n
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm curious and
I'm curious if there are people who um
might participate in this or or who
might also share their story in one way
or another of um kind of overcoming that
or reform um and so I was just curious
if that's a part of it as well or if
it's yes so we have two speakers in the
program um one was a child and her
father she was in car accidents with her
father drunk driving and so she's made
it her life mission to connect with
other victims and kind of help them move
forward um we have another speaker in
our program who her DUI was a wakeup
call that she was also battling
addiction and now she runs a rehab day
Center and provides counseling to other
people thank you I appreciate
that see enough further questions thank
you thank
krian good morning Aron krian general
counsel for the judicial branch um I
just wanted to compliment representative
Murphy not just because she represents
my parents in marac and I see that I
just headed off the police officer that
protects my parents in marac um but she
she brought a very broad group of people
together to take a look at the bill um
I'm just one of them and and the
implementation concerns the Judiciary
has on what is really a policy
expression what's the most important
part of the bill that that I I leave to
your determination um I just always
appreciate when Representatives give us
that opportunity to make sure that we
can implement it um and and she did that
with not just the judicial branch but
many other people um and I know given
this committee's um great emphasis on
thoroughness and diligence that that
would be F to you so I just wanted to
take a moment to come and and mention
that she had done
that thank you and were there or are
there any concerns from the Judiciary as
Implement no we can implement it if it's
your policy determination that it should
be
implemented thank
you see no questions thank you Brian the
Le thank you Mr chair and the members of
the committee I'll keep my comments
brief um I just want to let you know
that I did participate in the program I
took the online course and I've been a
police officer for 26 years um have had
to deliver those messages of someone's
passing and I can tell you that as soon
as I took this program I immediately
felt impacted by it um it truly is wide
ranging when you're talking about the
offenders the victims and that ripple
effect that you don't really think about
when you're making those actions when
you're doing them you know 20 years
after where people still medical bills
that are racking up that aren't being
paid by Insurance um personally I
thought it was very very impactful and
that's why I reel to representative
Murphy who's done a phenomenal job
Gathering all the stakeholders and
trying to present what I think is a is a
great bill so I just want to say I
personally uh took the program and I
think it's well worthwhile even if it
can get you know five out of 10 you know
half people have changed their behaviors
I think it's worthwhile so thank you
thank you I see no questions thank you
for your testimony so anyone Reon to
testify in this bill who hasn't done so
hearing
e
387 good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee um thank you for hearing
this bill today I thought it was going
to go to environment and agriculture but
because there are penalties involved I
think that's why it came here um my name
is Janet wall I'm State Rep been here 20
terms and I've never filed a frivolous
Bill and there have been all kinds of
comments made about the balloon bill but
this is a serious matter uh this bill
has come before us in the house before
uh back in 2007 and passed the house on
a Voice vote on consent it went to the
Senate and that's where it died because
the bill at that time focused only on
penalties not on education or anything
else um I'm sponsoring this bill on
behalf of a constituent who asked me for
three years in a row to please do
something and I honestly am embarrassed
to say perhaps that I didn't take it
seriously because it had died before but
he's a very well-respected businessman
who goes out deep sea fishing when he's
able to have time off from work when
he's in the state and he showed me late
this last summer a massive pile of
balloons I'm 55 A2 that balloon pile of
balloons was taller than I am and as
wide as his table that he had pulled up
just from that weekend alone being off
the coast of New Hampshire uh he said
This is Not Unusual this happens and
I've heard about it from other people
and I have never seen the evidence and
I'm sorry he couldn't be here today he
is out of state
but once he showed me that I thought
we've got a problem and we need to do
something about it and it's not only New
Hampshire um I have with me and um if
you need back up I need the original
bill from back in 2007 and all the
background information on testimony
votes and this that and the other um I
have that to share with you if you need
it um I have the amendment that came in
at that time um and I have copies of all
the laws from the 10 other states that
have passed this bill um the most recent
state was
Florida and prior to it passing in
Florida and again I've got the copies if
you need these if you don't I'll hang on
to them prior to that new uh the New
York Times had an article I'll only read
part of it to you balloons released in
the sky don't go to heaven they often
end up in oceans and waterways where
there and I don't know if this number is
accurate 32 times more are likely to
kill seabirds and other types of plastic
debris is found among the balloons um
balloons contribute to the increase in
micras plastic pollution which is
harmful to every living creature and we
all know that from what we've been going
through in recent years up here as well
it's not only the sea creatures that are
being damaged by it but the environment
is well uh living here in New Hampshire
I I come from a family of mountain
climbers when we're able to and um doing
the 4,000 Footers in numerous times not
we found litter in our beautiful
mountains but we found balloons just a
few months ago um I was not able to get
to this area where I found a cluster of
six or seven at least maybe eight
Balloons all tied together in a tree a
mile from my house where they came from
I don't know years ago we found a
balloon in our yard with a little note
on it from somebody down in Pennsylvania
wanting us to get in touch with them and
say where the balloon had finally landed
um these things drift around we don't
know where they're going to land we
don't know what's going to happen we
don't know about what animals are going
to ingest them and what's going to
happen to those animals fish are
affected um they did I think it's called
an acopy on a whale and determined that
it had ingested some balloons and it had
an intestinal blockage from the strings
or the ribbons whatever they were
connecting all those balloons um birds
get caught and and I've got pictures I
can show you if you need um birds get
caught in the uh W excuse me in the
strings and in the ribbons that tie
these balloons together I have two
pictures of birds that have been tied up
like that um it does happen this is
important what I'm asking for in this
bill is different from what the bill
asked for in 2007 again that Bill had
strong bipartisan support from the house
it passed on the consent calendar Voice
vote went into the Senate but all it
called for was penalties I'm not doing
that yes there's a penalty attached to
this as you'll see in the bill as you
read it but what it's asking for is when
these bills when these balloons are sold
put a tag on them just put a little tag
on that says these do uh cause hazards
to the environment and to Wildlife
Wildlife on the land as well as in the
sea just put a little tag on it to warn
people about that and actually um
someone said well this is going to hurt
the balloon industry it's not going to
hurt the balloon industry people still
love balloons and decorate with with
them and such um the T the store of
Market Basket sells balloons and they
sell them with a clip or weight on the
bottom of them that's all you really
need also you can put that tag on the we
you can put it on the string just have
it somewhere but it reminds people just
don't let these things go it's a lot of
fun watching balloons go up in the
sky but what goes up does come down and
there are consequences to this um I'm
asking that if you take this seriously
and I have come to the point where I am
taking it seriously now put a tag on the
balloons when they're sold it's not
going to hinder marketing at all it's
not going to stop the balloon industry
from producing balloons it's not going
to hurt enforcement one of the problems
with the other bill that uh failed in
the senate in 2007 was it relied on Fish
and Game to handle all this I I can't do
that to that agency we all know it's the
least funded uh agency Department in our
state and they're already burdened with
all the search and rescue efforts they
make all year long up in the mountains
um this is so that any law enforcement
officer can issue a ticket you know
you're violating the law um you're not a
criminal but there is a violation here
and make people aware that this is a
serious issue um I was at a funeral for
a newborn baby a few years ago it was
one of the saddest things I've ever
attended and at theend and we were all
at the cemetery and we were all handed
little note cards to write so we did not
knowing what the consequences were be
next thing we knew hundreds of balloons
were passed out we were to attach these
notes to the balloons and send them off
into the sky um I had a really hard time
doing that I really did because we all
know that again what goes up does come
down um I asked for you to take this
very seriously the states that have
passed the law that this is invi
California Connecticut Rhode Island
Delaware Tennessee Virginia Hawaii Maine
Maryland and Florida is the most recent
one there are a number of municipalities
that have also passed ordinances so that
people won't release balloons places
like Louisville Kentucky The Hamptons
New York rville North Carolina galston
Texas and Bainbridge Island Washington
and other communities have done on that
as well um people are beginning to be
aware that balloons really become trash
they don't just evaporate we need to be
aware that there's a way to dispose of
these responsibly if you want balloons
okay decorate with them there's a way to
decorate you've seen balloon arches just
like arches with flowers and such if you
want to um scatter something uh someone
suggested scatter rose petals or
something but don't have it so you have
particles of plastic or going into the
ocean and into the environment so again
there's a way to manage this it's just
good common sense and asking that you
take this seriously and please uh
consider passing it again ton of the
states have done it we had it before
without um the steps for
Education all we had was a penalty
before which I don't think ever worked
for anything I mean when we're raising
our children we just don't have
penalties we offer options for better
behavior and hopefully that's what
happens here um thank you very
much thank you any
questions repr
amuse have you seen the the pictures of
the seabirds that are posted on the US
fish and wildlife site uh that have been
killed by balloons and STS somewhere in
all these papers I have a picture or two
of them and yeah they do get tangled up
thank you thank you very much it it does
happen
representative new thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
so I I wonder if you think that the um
educational piece around this is to a
point where it makes sense to have
consequences can you repeat that please
I wonder if you think that the awareness
and educational piece of letting people
know that this is you know that they're
this is harmful to our environment for
example you know we used to do this for
uh people who had lost someone to
overdose we would do the black balloons
and we would release that my kids used
to write notes on balloons and send them
up to their dad kind of thing um and of
course but of course we stop that
because we realize oh this is not good
for the environment now of course that
wasn't 20 plus balloons that was quite a
few but that it's been a long
progression so my question is do you
think that the um education and
awareness piece is at a point where it
makes sense for us to say yes people
really probably should know and
releasing that many is worth having a
consequence I think any knowledge
anybody has is helpful and if they put
it to good use it's even better um and
the penalty is just there for people who
intentionally will relase great big
clusters of them and I do realize it's
hard to enforce something like this very
hard however there are balloons that are
released with names of companies and
such on them I don't know if anybody
wants to go far enough um if we try this
and it doesn't work um if they want to
go far enough so that when people buy a
cluster of balloons um that they at
least let the um um store or the shop
wherever they're buying them know who
they are so that they can be traced back
I don't want to go that far um I just
again this is for people who
intentionally let balloons go and I
don't think they mean anything bad I
think people just weren't thinking and
it's the same thing as disposing of
cigarettes or papers or anything like
that that we've had educate the people
get them to know what's going on and
what can happen and have people realize
that these are realistic things not just
these extreme pictures one bird want
it's not like that um I I worry about
the fish that we eat you know what on
Earth did that fish ingest um before we
caught it and ate it um I I wonder a lot
of us wonder about what we're eating
today and what the consequences are what
we're doing to our Earth and we all love
New Hampshire and our natural resources
let's do a little bit better to protect
our wildlife and ourselves thank you
thank
you representable
CS thank you for taking my question
um sometimes when you it is fun to watch
balloons go up in the air um just
recently there was an article on the
news about the percentage of people with
Alzheimer's that had
microplastics in their
brain uh and are you aware of that and
it it uh you just think of all these
things in the environment they all come
home to roost at some
point thank you very much for your
comments and for sharing that knowledge
yes I was aware of that and for all
we've been through in recent years
regarding past and such we know that
every one of us has something in us um
just do the best we can to live as
healthily as we can and let's just add
one more little feature to safety thank
thank
you see you no further questions thank
you for bringing us the Bill thank you
very much oh Mr chairman um it's the
only time I've ever sponsored a bill
that's not
bipartisan the only time I've ever
sponsored a bill that doesn't have a
geographic spread people around the
state and it's just because of my
situation I wasn't able to do that this
year um but we do know from past history
that the last bill that didn't even come
and educate people had that kind of
much you could ask if you want folks to
look at them but we don't have to have
them seeing no one out here by closes
public
p.m.
e
good afternoon everybody welcome back
it is 1:00 I hope everybody enjoyed
their lunch representative
Mooney um I'm going to open the public
hearing for House Bill
and welcome the sponsor to introduce his
Bill thank you for the record
representative Roy Rockingham 32 I am
here to introduce House Bill
466 relative to refusal of consent to
testing to determine alcohol
concentration penalty for aggravated
driving and
intoxicated here's the situation New
Hampshire is the worst or if not the
worst almost the worst state in the
entire country for refusals to take
breathalizer tests the reason being the
penalty for not taking it is the same as
taking it so why take it
um if we can get people to take these
tests we can get data we can get people
into programs we can get them help if
they don't we can't and so we're
spinning our wheels and our ouis are
getting worse and people are getting
killed we need to stiffen these
penalties to incentivize people to take
the test otherwise really we're we're
just like I said we're spinning our
Wheels um the the member of the State
Police behind me he going to testify
he's going to give you some hard data um
everything I'll tell you is just
anecdotal after meeting with them and
their request for this bill I feel that
is urgent that we take this action we do
not want to be last in the country for
this there's plenty of things would like
to be but this isn't it so um I'd be
willing to take any questions on this
but I would defer um to the trooper
data thank you very much representative
Muse has a
question is the is the text for this
bill um the same as s sp48 that we
considered last year I don't know
because I didn't sponsor that and I
don't really recall um it it could be I
don't know thank you yeah representative
I do re remember that bill that the day
that we heard it it's probably similar
but I don't know that it is actually the
same right seeing no further questions
McFarland absolutely when you when you
have a SE if you could just introduce
yourself so we could um have that for
the
record good afternoon everybody my name
is Lieutenant Chris storm I am from the
New Hampshire office of Highway Safety
the division of state
police good afternoon my name is Ryan
McFarland I'm the administrator for the
New Hampshire Department of Safety
Bureau of
hearings so the New Hampshire State
Police um we um highly endorse um HB 466
which we seek to increase the penalties
for license loss result resulting from
the refusal to take post arrest tests
this measure is crucial to our efforts
in reducing DWI incidents and to keep
the most atrisk drivers off our roads in
New Hampshire currently uh as you heard
um chairman Roy say we have one of the
highest refusal rates in the entire
country this undermines our ability to
combat impaired driving out on our
roadways and right now we have
approximately 70% of all of our fatal
crashes are result of impaired driving
um this highlights the urgent need to
stricter consequences for those who
refuse to cooperate with law enforcement
when it comes to driving well
Intoxicated by implementing this will um
the increase of license loss penalties
will deter individuals from refusing
tests and promote safer driving
environments for all residents and
visitors to our state and I'll let um
attorney McFarland kind of speak to the
the hearing side of
that good afternoon uh we're really
attacking the refusal rate here in New
Hampshire the the national highway
traffic safety administration has issued
reports uh Nationwide and Nationwide the
refusal rate and I put this in my
written testimony uh in the it's usually
around the 25% range in New Hampshire in
the past three years it's in the written
testimony it's always been around in in
2022 was 70% 2023 the refusal rate was
68% and in 2024 the refusal rate was
69% uh so this bill would uh it's going
to uh help lower uh or attack the
refusal High refusal rate in four
different Avenues um it will increase
the administrative license suspensions
uh for those who refuse so in the first
instance of a refusal it will increase
it from a six-month suspension to a
one-year suspension uh as is currently
indicated uh the current with it's a
six-month suspension for a First Defense
whether it's a refusal or a test over so
this will increase it for a refusal in a
second or subsequent refusal
uh or where an individual has a prior
DWI on their record it'll increase it
from a 2-year revocation to a three-year
revocation uh so that's the first part
of the bill that will attack that now
the bill also will add out of state
either DWI convictions or out ofate
refusals currently the B uh the statute
does not address any out ofate DWI
convictions so an individual can have an
out ofate DWI conviction in other states
Massachusetts Maine Vermont uh they have
then they have a New Hampshire driver's
license they refuse a test here in New
Hampshire and it's treated as a first
offense first refusal and a six-month
suspension uh so this will add language
to include an out ofate DWI and out
ofate refusal uh when we're calculating
whether a person has a subsequent
refusal uh on their record uh the the
bill then goes on to also try to
increase individuals uh awareness and
ability to get into counseling once they
they plead anyone who pleads guilty or
is found guilty of a DW must complete
What's called the impaired driver Care
Management program uh which is
counseling associated with the DWI
conviction this bill allows a six-month
re uh reduction of that administrative
suspension uh if they plead guilty to
the DWI and undergo that treatment so uh
so that 12-month uh refusal will then be
dropped down to a six-month refusal if
they plead guilty to the DW and go
through the counseling uh necessary and
the three-year will go down to two and a
half years so this bill allows for that
reduction as well to somebody who pleads
to gwi or is found guilty of the DWI uh
then the last one also to try to make
things uh fair in the process also
amends the aggravated DWI currently
right now an aggravated DWI an
individual who tests over uh twice the
de the legal limit which is a016 would
be an aggravated DWI that's an
individual who's done what we've asked
them to do they've submitted to the
requested test and now they're they're
more than dou legal limit they're a 0.16
or raer they can be charged with
aggravate DWI and the way that the
current statute is uh there's a
mandatory jail sentence that goes along
with that so this amendment to the would
would allow that uh that sentence to
jail sentence to be suspended by the
court discretion of the uh the
prosecutor the police officer and also
the court to amend that to uh allow to
try to give some incentive individuals
who have taken the test not to be unduly
burdened by a required jail sentence
because these are individuals who are
doing what we've asked them to do and
submit to the testing as part of that so
uh those are the four points of the bill
that I I I think are very important to
address in kind um and willing to take
have representative
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um just to
clarify on the last point you just
mentioned so if someone currently
without prior um like conviction gets
arrested for double the amount they have
the mandatory sentence and so this would
remove the ma mandatory sentence part or
as if they had a prior interaction as
well does that make sense yeah
absolutely men said so if you have a
prior DWI the sentence will whether you
take the test or don't take the test if
you have convicted of a subsequent
offense there is a jail time that is
associated with that what we're saying
is if you are a first-time offender you
take the test and you blow over the 0.16
right now it is a mandatory jail
sentence we're saying that jail sentence
can be suspended it still can be imposed
for the most egregious um situations but
it can be suspended um so that there is
more incentive to actually take the test
and cooperate so that we actually can
get those convictions and get those
individuals off the roadway um just
because cooperated doesn't mean you
should go to jail yeah okay thank you
can I ask a follow up um I was just
curious if you could share with us any
any other um like obviously not a whole
in-depth thing but any broad thing you
might be able to share about like what
other um Avenues are being explored to
deal with this problem you know I know
that last year we increased the fine for
like over serving people if you're in a
bar or restaurant I'm just curious like
what else is being explored because
obviously this is a massive problem and
you know yeah we've looked at um and I I
can speak to what we've looked at is a
traffic safety commission we've looked
at this through the office of Highway
Safety the department of safety um I
know the chiefs of police we've all
looked at this in different Avenues um
there are many different things that
we've looked at um to get into specifics
um what we're there are no real
specifics and nationally we're kind of
the same problem the problem that we're
seeing in New Hampshire though is that
refusal rate seems to be our biggest
hurdle to get over to try to stop some
of this and stop some of the recidivism
of this because it's basically hey if I
refuse to take the test this is going to
get pled down or they're going to have
the evidence or they're not going to
have any and these people are getting
right back on the roadways driving and
then we're having the same problems over
and over again um so that's what we're
seeing and this is what we're trying to
fix um as far as other avenues or other
ways we haven't had there hasn't been
really any other suggestions or anything
like that other than fixing this refusal
problem first and then we can build upon
on see seeing no further questions thank
bite Buton on the bottom there sorry all
right I apologize first time which is
why I didn't have enough copies I do
apologize um thank you all for your time
my name is Alexandria Morell I am the
traffic safety resource prosecutor at
the Department of Justice I'm here as a
representative of the Attorney General
in support of House Bill
466 the amendment on page 1 line
14-9 allows the DMV to review equivalent
prior out of state refusals to determine
if the refusal that occurs in New
Hampshire is truly a firsttime or a
subsequent violation as of 2019 all
states in the United States have implied
consent laws which stipulate that a
driver must consent to being tested um
having their blood
tested um if they are suspected of being
an impaired
driver New Hampshire is a member of the
driver compact what that means is that
the states that are a part of this
compact exchange information concerning
licensed suspensions and traffic
violations so not parking tickets but
major motor vehicle offenses the theme
is one driver one license one record
more importantly with this theme is that
the language in other statutes already
takes into account if you have
convictions and other jurisdictions that
are similar as noted um the DWI
subsequent events and driving after
revocation
or suspension if it was for a
DUI so that makes sense to have this
amendment that recognizes those out of
state convictions for the refusal law
under the current law there is only 180
day suspension for your first refusal
for subsequent uh refusals the license
suspension can be up to 2 years the
Amendments seek to increase the
administrative license suspension from
180 days to one year so 6 months to a
year and then up to three years for
subsequent refusals these enhanced
penalties are necessary to prevent
drivers from trying to skirt the
intended purposes of our criminal laws
Savvy and unfortunately most often
repeat offenders hope to receive a minor
Administration uh license suspension for
their criminal behavior that is
dangerous to our society and those
criminal Behavior the statutes we have
created are what are appropriate for the
crime that they have committed thus the
issue is penalties for refusal are less
severe than criminal penalties for
failing the test and therefore we must
enact these
amendments If a driver feels that
they're over the limit the current
suspension system incentivizes refusals
prior to becoming the traffic safety
resource prosecutor I was a public def
vender for 10 years um 5 Years first in
New York and then 5 Years in New
Hampshire when I was assigned a DWI case
I knew immediately if there was a
refusal the case was likely going to
resolve in a plea deal or a trial that I
could win without a test prosecutors
generally are unable to seek Justice and
obtain a conviction part of this problem
is CSI jurors want to see scientific
evidence on every case even though
legally that's not required
in my experience personally as a public
defender people who had already been
arrested would often
refuse that is because during their
subsequent investigation they knew if
they didn't have the evidence they'd
likely get a plea deal to what's called
a non-true DWI first um this is a legal
sentence unfortunately where there's an
enhancement of oneyear loss of license
but 6 months can be suspended if they
engage in treatment and pay all Their
fines this obviously shows close to the
180 days so whether you refuse or if you
have the ALS you're only receiving that
six months license suspension if there's
no evidence compare that to an
aggravated DWI as mentioned earlier is
if you blow over a .16 BAC or even if
you have a subsequent DWI fence then you
would have longer suspensions and also
more conditions
so by enabling somebody to do just the
ALS and either get a dismissal or a
reduction they're avoiding the criminal
penalties that are associated with
licensed
suspensions for those who oppose House
Bill 466 they may argue that the
amendments are punitive in nature but
you need to read the entire bill as a
whole the Amendments actually create
Equity DWI related fatalities and
offenses are a serious concern in New
hampsh
you are more likely to die from a motor
vehicle accident than from a homicide in
2022 we had 204 drivers involved in
fatal accidents of those 204 drivers
involved only
71% were willing to give a BAC test 18%
of those drivers who were tested had a
BAC higher than
0.15 that's almost double the legal
limit of
08 which that means that individual
could be charged with that aggravated
DWI which has those enhanced penalties
longer suspension mandatory jail time
and that's even if they are the first
offender which I believe that was one of
the questions earlier so if you blow 0
uh1
16.17 first time you're ever interacting
with the police your charge is the
aggravated
DWI and as I mentioned there is a
mandatory jail time of 5 days currently
with the proposed amendment that would
allow the judge to May suspend versus
right now there is no discretion for the
judge and so that's drawing your
attention to page two line
9-8 and so this amendment seeks to focus
on treatment and not just punishment
when you remove the mandatory jail time
people are incentivized to take the test
as mentioned earlier by attorney
McFarland since 2013 all drivers
convicted of a wi offense in New
Hampshire are required to go to an
impaired driver Care Management program
this allows them to be screened there's
an evaluation to determine if there is a
substance use disorder and participate
in treatment education or recovery
Support Services if needed so a high BAC
that .16 .17 I've seen some as high as
unfortunately .30 can indicate a high
need for treatment for each individual
case the results can determine the
appropriate rehabilitative options so in
conclusion the Amendments outlined in
House Bill 466 combat refusals to
decrease DWI related
fatalities properly identify and
sentence drivers who put everyone at
risk and three provide evidence for
proper
treatment does anybody have any
questions
yes representative Muse
thank you for taking my
question what happens when somebody
actually refuses a test so you you still
have a case you have to prove how do you
prove that case against the person so
the only way to prove that would be
either obser officer observations um if
there were any videos in the booking
room so it's more looking at how
somebody was interacting with the police
um if there's Cruiser cam seeing their
actual driving behavior um but with a
test result I can personally say every
single DWI trial or litigation I had I
won because there were no breath results
or
blood followup
follow with the Department of Safety and
and many law enforcement agencies in New
Hampshire now equipping their officers
with body cams and car cams has that
changed is it is it has it gotten any
easier to prove these
cases to some degree with body cam but I
think like the odor of alcohol you can't
sense that by watching a video not all
police departments have body cams right
now unfortunately as we are aware both
state and federally there might be
funding issues upcoming so this law
covers all of New Hampshire so we have
to think about those jurisdictions and
those departments that can't afford dash
cam or body cam cameras do help
especially in Booking rooms that's one
reason that almost all booking rooms do
have videos because there's a waiting
period so you can kind of see how
somebody is interacting what their body
movement is for the 20 minute period but
overall the videos aren't
you else right see no further questions
everyone we we have one more person once
to testify do you want to
wait okay it's a response
use also you have to keep in mind that
um some people while they're being when
they get to trial they're going to claim
they have previously existing injuries I
have a bad back so you can see a video
of a booking tape with somebody
stumbling but without actually being
there the evidence isn't that strong
because they had previous medical
conditions and things of this nature
that they claim
my my name is yhav and I oppose this
bill um I think often we look we look at
this issue in in the wrong eyes um the
Constitution both of New Hampshire and
the United States provides people to not
um have to testify against themselves
and by making people submit to tests
under blackmail of the idea that they
would suspend their license for
potentially up to a
year um it gives a lot of force to a
police officer who can stop someone and
then just say oh I smell alcohol and
that would give the kick off the the
process with with no real evidence for
them
to to potentially and a lot of people
get get get uh convicted for DUIs when
there was no good evidence to it and
this type
of of
punishment um really really goes to it
goes against the spirit of the of the
Constitution and constitutional rights
in general uh the the DMV suspended
license often for reasons that have
nothing related to driver license uh to
driving violations in the first place
and it's just a although we the law view
is driving as a privilege it's hard to
imagine living in today's age especially
if you live in a small rural area where
you you have to drive to work and
everything is a driver in distance um it
it's a a huge burden and it shifts the
burden of of uh innocence onto onto
people when there are no evidence at
that point to the contrary so if
somebody gets stopped now they need to
prove that they're not driving Under the
Influence by giving blood to the
government um I think it is very
unfairly shifts burden to people to
prove that they are not drunk rather
giving the rather letting the government
the prosecution to prove that somebody
thank
you is there anybody else with us
wishing to testify on House Bill 466
that has not turned in a paint card
seeing none I will close the public
1:45
e
welcome back everybody I am going to
open the public hearing for House Bill
482 and welcome the sponsor to
introduce thank you madam chairman um
for the record representative Roy
Rockingham 32 I'm here today introducing
House Bill 42 um on behalf of the
Department of Public Safety at their
request this bill would increase the
penalty for driving over 100 mes hour in
the last 6 years in New Hampshire based
on um statistics glean from Air
enforcement the number of people who
have been caught or apprehended going
over 100 miles hour has increased
230% um so the number of fatalities are
way way up um these accidents are
horrific when you start getting at this
speed you start talking about a head-on
collision at that and you're getting
into um mathematics that compounds when
you're talking about two vehicles
colliding at speed weighing so many tons
we also have these new electric vehicles
that are very fast they're they're
really neat but they're also very very
heavy um because of the batteries the
car is Mo the weight of the car is
mostly batteries and as you know an
object a motion tends to stay in motion
until acted upon by an object or equal
or opposite speed so when it hits
something going that fast um it is going
to be destructive beyond belief so the
people behind me are going to be able to
again to put some um statistics to this
to tell you why this is necessary um
cars are going much faster and
unfortunately people are dying and I
think we need to bring this to the
Public's attention that this is a very
serious issue and I'd be willing to take
questions but as I said the folks behind
me are the experts and we'll have the
numbers thank you for taking me back to
my seventh grade uh science class with
Mr good neack on
inera um yall thinkk think I'm kidding
and I'm not um I I don't see any
you is there anybody here that wishes to
testify on House Bill 482 that has not
card oh look at that ask and you shall
receive
your Lambert they
go Lieutenant storm did you guys want to
go
together
yep a lot Mi Mr Lambert and I are old
friends over a speed limit sign as a
matter of
fact
oh by the way I didn't get what I wanted
so
back good afternoon again again I'm
Lieutenant Chris storm I am uh the leaz
on to the office of Highway Safety for
the division of State Police and we are
here to talk about the increase in
speeds over 100 miles an hour on our
roadways um today we um the New
Hampshire State Police and the
department of safety wholeheartedly um
support um HB 482 which we seek to
increase penalties for individuals who
drive in exceeding 100 m mil an hour as
these traffic speeds on our roadways
continue to escalate the N Hampshire
State Police has um reported a
concerning rise in incidents of
excessive speeding this trend um
necessitates the implementation of a
more stringent penalties to hold the
most dangerous drivers accountable for
their actions over the past few years we
have witnessed a steady increase in
these alarming speeds and is imperative
that we make uh take decisive action to
ensure the safety of all of New
Hampshire roadway users by en uh
endorsing ing uh House Bill 482 we can
work together to create safer driving
environment and deterring Reckless
Behavior on our highways um as
representative Roy just said um I I
actually have the pleasure and honor of
um um commanding our um aircraft unit as
well and I can tell you right now um
we're seeing it every single day out
here on our roadways and it is um scary
um before um many years ago we would see
hey a couple times we'd see people going
100 101 um on various you know very
limited um it was kind of a big deal to
get somebody that was traveling over 100
miles an hour we're getting two three
every time our airplane goes out and
flies um on all of our major interstates
and it's um very very scary um our
numbers are soaring as far as um
reckless driving goes for people that
are actually being apprehended for
driving over 100 miles an hour um just
in the state police and I can't imagine
some of the other towns or some of the
other surface streets that are having
people that are traveling um in excess
of 100 miles an hour so what we found is
that we need to do something to St to
sty this from happening because often
times people will go into court um
they'll get the regular reckless driving
charge or have it reduced to 99 miles an
hour and they'll just get a a simply a
fine and that's it we have to start
holding this accountable because we are
seeing our crashes um the speeds are
increasing on these crashes that we're
going and Mr Lambert's going to talk um
about the fact that our roadways are not
built for this so turn right over to
Bill good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
um my name is Bill Lambert I'm the New
Hampshire dot highway safety act of
Transportation uh administrator um in
our previous conversation um I was the
state traffic engineer responsible for
speed limits um the department of
transportation's officially neutral on
this bill although we support anything
that we can do to bring speeds down
because we agree that the uh the crashes
and the severity of the crashes are
certainly out of control at this point
in time we're seeing my program is
responsible for reducing fatal and
serious injury crashes and we're seeing
those numbers where they would like to
go down towards zero they they're at
best leveling off and in some cases
they're they're increasing I provided
written testimony uh I was coached by um
the current Deputy speaker in the years
past I don't need to read that testimony
but I do want to summarize some key
points for for for you folks one would
be the concept of design speed when
we're designing and building highways we
generally use a design speed as a basis
for our design and that speed is usually
the posted speed limit plus a little bit
for a factor of safety and that sets the
minimum criteria for what we design uh
highways for and if that's the minimum
criteria what we're finding is Decades
of using that design speed to design and
build highways people are safe at the
design speed but they're comfortable
going much higher than that um so now
we're talking more in terms of Target
speed so having a maximum speed that we
designed for and it would be
uncomfortable to go higher than that
we're a long way from changing our
highways to be self- enforcing in that
manner it's going to take years before
we get to that point but the the design
speed for instance in horizontal
alignment that would determine the
minimum horizontal curve and super
elevation
combination um that would keep a vehicle
on the road on the outside of a curve
and when and if that's based on the
design speed and people are doing twice
that design speed the physics just don't
work I mean they're likely to go off the
outside uh the other things like
intersections and passing that are in
here um I'll let you read but one of the
other things that's pretty significant
based on our experience this summer is
um things like roadside clearance we
tend to uh have a risk management
analysis as far as when we'll put guide
rail up and that's either for a fixed
object or for divided highways for the
opposite barrel and in October as you
all know last year three straight
Wednesday we saw somebody cross the
median of 95 and hit somebody in the
other Barrel those highways are designed
to be safe for that distance you don't
need to put barrier there but we're
finding when people are traveling a lot
faster than that risk management
assessment they get to the other side
and when they get to the other side
really bad things happen so it's
important to know the the consequences
of how we design highways and why and
what happens when people exceed our
assumptions when they're traveling on
the highway and I guess with that
representative n thank you madam chair
and thanks for taking my question I'm
just looking at the language and I'm
just trying to make sure that I'm
getting it clear um and so what it says
is that um a violation and find not less
than $750 uh plus penalty assessment for
first offense um and then that goes up
to 1,000 for the second offense but then
it goes on to say um his or her uh
license or operating priv privilege
shall be revoked for a period of 90 days
for the first offense so I'm trying to
just group exactly what it is for the
first offense and for subsequent
offenses so a violation um uh $750 fine
and revoked uh for 90 days on the first
offense yes ma'am okay and then the same
except for $1,000 and it could be up to
a year for the second offense that is
correct and we'll leave that to the
Court's discretion depending on the how
egregious it is or um you know the
obviously the length of time so we'll
leave that to the courts to discretion
to to be able to make that determination
and the whole point of that so you know
is the fact that a regular Reckless
operation is just a 60-day loss of
license with a $500 fine so this is
something that we already have traveling
over a 100 miles an hour is already
Reckless operation but that penalty
needs to be stiffer for people that are
going that fast um it is um we're just
seeing it so so much that we have to do
something to stop this okay thank you
and can I just quick followup I just um
the only thing I actually I I agree um
but um my question is you know from the
second one it says um 90 days up to a
year for the second offense and I would
think that we' want to make sure that it
was more than 90 days for the second
offense if you've already again we did
that for a couple different reasons one
one of which is it depending on how how
long the time that's been between
offenses if there there's no there's no
limitation when they look back at that
right so you could have been 16 years
old and now you're 5 years old is that
is that really fair right oh okay that
makes sense thank you I appreciate it
representative
lels thank you for taking my question
I'm all for this H I'm old enough to
remember folks swagin had 40 horsepower
40 horsepower when I was growing up in
the 60s if you had a car that had more
than 300 horsepower that was a super car
I mean it was is high powerered
today you you watch auctions and they
have 700 800 a th000 horsepower now who
the heck needs that kind of car
representative lelles yes my my qu I'm
getting to my question please do my
question
is couldn't we have some way when people
register a car that once they go over a
certain C amount of horsepower that they
have to pay extra for that registration
and put it into enforcement maybe we
have a plane over every single Highway
all right that there's no sense in
having cars that go representative what
okay I'm I'm done
what was there a question yes the
question is couldn't we use
registrations to increase the amount of
enforcement that we have I believe that
would probably be a question for a
director morasco of the Department of
Motor Vehicles I probably couldn't make
any uh assumption on that
I thank you I can't imagine having to
punish somebody to to register the car
that hasn't done anything and meum by
the way is the uh auction that is
Muse I I do have a question um and I'm
I'm just curious if there are other
tools tools in the in the toolbox aside
from from increasing penalties so other
strategies that the do and the
department of safety may be pursuing to
get a handle on this problem because I
think one of the things that we've seen
is that increasing penalties isn't
necessarily uh doesn't necessarily lead
to the kind of behavior change a lot of
times that we would like it
to um I would say other than um some
infrastructure changes or which are
obviously a tremendous amount of money
um the education piece we we've tried we
we are using every Avenue that we can to
um to get this um to get this out there
um we are constantly um trying to um
post on our Social Media stuff through
the office of Highway Safety the state
police the department of safety um we're
um also working in conjunction with the
Department of Transportation to
constantly get this message out there um
we are trying to um get this stuff out
um as far as we can get to every time
that we have a significant event like
that where someone's traveling in an
excessive amount that we try to get it
out to the media so that we have a lot
of coverage on this to say we we are not
okay with this uh as a state and um we
have lots of comments and lots of other
things that are just asking us what
we're doing to try to do this and this
is the best Avenue right now that we can
think of to do this can I follow
up so Lieutenant storm and I and our
colleagues have been working for a lot
of a long time trying to how to address
it how do we change the behavior as
representative lelle said we've got
vehicles that are doing 100 miles an
hour plus we've got people that choose
to do more than 100 miles an hour so
somehow we have to change those two
things um when we were little kids we
learned that slow and steady wins the
race right we watch bug's bunny he
always loses to the tortoise uh we've
been promoting the slow and steady it's
not a race uh I'm happy to pass these
around we've got some Billboards we've
got some other Outreach uh we've been
sending are driving towards zero folks
to schools all across the state to try
to get to that lower that the younger
drivers to get them convinced it's like
seat belts when when my kids when I
started putting my kids in a car and
having them wear seat belts they
reminded my whole family that they had
to put seat belts on so if we can get
the younger drivers conditioned to think
that slow and steady is the safer way to
go and we're doing as much as we can
this is one more tool in the toolbox
have we ever seriously in this state
looked into things like speed cams I
know for my own personal experience um
having been uh flaged one time for going
uh 55 through a 35 mph Zone in
Washington DC and getting a surprise in
the mail that cost me over $200 one
thing I know is I never went over 35
miles an hour again on that stretch of
highway uh it seems pretty effective I
think I think I I can take that so
there's a lot of activity on it used to
be automated enforcement and now the
federal government's calling it speed
safety cameras it's just a term it's
words um sometimes words matter uh we we
recognize in the state of New Hampshire
with the only state that doesn't have a
prime a seat belt law of any for adults
that that's a long uphill climb um so
while the dot is interested in it we
would we would try to pursue it more for
specific purposes because of the
challenges with a the automated
enforcement and B the um the use of
personal identification information uh
we'd be interested primarily in work
zones because that's where our people
are exposed to traffic whether it's the
uniformed officers tow truck drivers or
dot Personnel but we're a long way from
there it's it's on the radar but it's
not very close on the radar thank you
representative
Newman you clarify the
language could you just clarify the
language where it says not less than 75
plus penalty assessment is that
assessment for the crime of reckless
driving or did it go together or what
does that mean I'm sorry I I don't it's
15 and it just says penalty assessment
what is that is there a fine for re so
the penalty assessment is is is set by
the legislature so I think whatever the
penalty assessment is is what it's going
to be so I we we don't we're not asking
for anything in the the bill that would
have a a specific penalty assessment
other than what is already um
legislatively U appropriate but I mean
those is the penalty assessment
currently for excuse me
followup for the penalty
assessment there is a penalty ass a
current penalty assessment for reckless
driving yes on all fines there is that
okay and then that assessment is
included it's additional to the 750 yes
thank you and the same thing for the
seeing no further questions thank you
very
much is there anybody else with us
wishing to testify on houseb 482 that
has not turned in a pain card seeing
none I will close the public hearing
and we will be in recess for about 10
minutes our next hearing is at
2:15
e
good afternoon everybody it
is it is 2:15 and I do need to open up
the the hearing for House Bill 776 but
it appears our sponsor may have
inadvertently gone across the street so
I'm just going to recess for a moment if
you could just all give me a moment to
uh make a phone call and see if he is
still on campus so so I'm opening the
house the the the hearing for house B
776 and we will just be in a few minute
everybody
okay everybody um we
are we are going to um have
representative Muse is going to be kind
enough to introduce the bill and we will
have our
experts that are here to talk about the
bill and then if we need to I'll just
recess it when representative Roy is
back we can um take it up again if we
need to so with that I am reopening the
ing for House Bill 776 and uh
representative Muse the floor is
yours my name is representative David
Muse I represent Portsmouth Newington uh
and Newcastle and I'm introducing uh
this bill uh in L of the sponsor
representative Terry Roy um and uh if
you do have any questions on the bill uh
I would urge you to ask some of the
folks who are going to be testifying
after me who can speak to the need uh
for the bill better than I I can but
what I would like to say is that living
in Portsmouth and living close to I95 um
we have seen numerous uh incidents over
the years of people uh driving uh the
wrong way down 95 and getting themselves
and other people killed um uh I'm not
100% sure that anything that we do from
a legal perspective uh could help but
hopefully there are some things we can
do to discourage people from this kind
of behavior and um I'm looking forward
to hearing the other
testimony thank you very much
representative we appreciate the uh the
professional
got Lieutenant storm and Mr Lambert did
you guys want to uh tag team this again
to good afternoon again uh again I am
Lieutenant Chris storm the office of
Highway Safety liaison for the vision of
state
police good afternoon members of the
committee uh thanks for having us um
Bill Lambert New Hampshire dot highway
administrator so I'll just read you what
uh what I had prepared today um we
strongly support HB 776 which aims to
add wrongway driving to the list of
aggravated DWI offenses in New Hampshire
in recent years we have witnessed a
significant increase in wrongway driving
incidents with reports averaging nearly
one occurrence per day on our roadways
here in New
Hampshire many of these drivers are
often found to be impaired by drugs or
alcohol posing severe risk to themselves
and others by elevating the penalties
for traveling the wrong way in violation
of
26526 which is our divided ways statute
while impaired by alcohol or drugs
adding this to aggravated DWI we can
address an extremely dangerous behavior
that frequently results in fatal
consequences
New Hampshire's had several tragic cases
to include those of the U crash victim
Lizzy croak of marac on the ever
Turnpike killed by a wrongway driver um
just recently the Endicott Police
Sergeant Jeremy Cole on his way home
from work was killed by a wrongway
driver that started here in New
Hampshire and then just the other day as
many of you saw probably on the news a
wrongway driver traveled over 12 miles
striking two different Vehicles while
this underscores the urgent need for
stricter enforcement and stricter
penalties these examples highlight the
necessity of holding Reckless
preventable actions to a much higher
standard ultimately aiming to enhance
the safety of our roads for everybody
you good afternoon again um so the dot
is certainly partnering with our highway
safety officials and wrongway driving
has been on our radar for a very long
time
uh and until recently the the crash
numbers didn't necessarily warrant
specific action and we considered some
countermeasures for for years what we
would do to correct wrongway driving um
recently as Lieutenant storm has has
indicated the crash numbers have gone up
crash severity is always har harsh um so
we've we've established a a work group
between the two agencies and including
some of our local sa law enforcement
Partners to come up with a comprehensive
WR wrongway action plan uh to going to
representative M's point it's not just
looking at the penalty phase of it we're
looking at Aiden doing a network screen
of our entire Highway Network to
identify the highrisk locations uh
coming up with a hierarchy of counter
measures that we would use based on the
on the risk factors and in implementing
that I I know our neighbors to the South
um fairly recently tried a pilot project
where they added some pretty significant
technology to 10 pilot locations um
where they don't just detect the
wrongway driver and send them flashing
lights when he makes the wrong turn he
she um but they confirm a lot of the
drivers that go the wrong way at an
intersection will self-correct so they
have second set of detection uh further
up the ramp to confirm that they're
still going the wrong way um and then
that starts alerting the law enforcement
personnel and others that they may be a
wrong way driver on the road and then
there's a third set of detection that
confirms that they're actually on the
highway going the wrong way and what
Massachusetts does is that sends alerts
to the law enforcement Personnel it may
send messages to the message boards to
let the public know uh and and other
measures like that so that's part of
what we're working toward um but we also
want to make sure that drivers are aware
that there's a significant penalty uh
for going the wrong way and making those
kinds of decisions that that end up in
fatalities representative n thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I don't know if you said it so
I just want to um revisit if you if you
did um and I apologize if I didn't hear
it what percentage of uh wrongway
drivers are found to be
intoxicated that's a great question
representative and um I would say I
don't have the exact number for you
right now I can get that for you but it
is a majority of um those wrong way
drivers are actually impaired right
thank
you if if I could just have a quick
followup to to her question when you
say imp impaired not necessarily alcohol
but just substance impaired absolutely
it's both drugs and alcohol absolutely
all right thank you representative
Muse I did have a quick quick question
about the statute uh the divided highway
statute it's not a wrongway driving
statute it's a divided highway so if I'm
correct in interpreting it somebody who
actually is on a let's say a on a on a
highway with um letd say a stripe in the
middle kind of dividing both sides of
the highway who veers over under the
other side of the highway they could
also be prosecuted under this no
representative so I'll give you a prime
example in your District so if you
looked at like the route one bypass for
instance so it is actually divided under
26526 physical barrier I get you okay
thank
you any other question any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
very
much is
is there anybody else with us that
wishes to testify on House Bill 776 that
has not turned in a pink card okay so
seeing none I am going to I'm going to
recess this hearing and um as a courtesy
if our chairman just wants to reopen it
when we meet next Friday then he would
have that option if there's anything
that he needs to add but I'm pretty sure
that we we heard everything we need I
just think that's the the right thing to
do okay so with that that is in
recess and we are cranking right along
here friends um we actually are in
recess until 3:00 p.m. our next bill is
e
good afternoon everybody
um it is a lot of paperwork everywhere
okay we are going to open the public
473 and I welcome representative Nelson
legislation repr representative rice you
want to you guys want to tag team this
okay if you could just um obviously make
sure you both introduce yourselves and
um it's all
you thank you madam chair I'm Jody
Nelson representing
Derry and I'm Kim rice representing
Lichfield thank you Madame chairwoman
and thank you members of the committee
for your time this afternoon I know
you've had a long day so far um
introducing you to HB 473 which would be
criminal criminalizing multiple forms of
exposing children to controlled
substances and allowing law enforcement
to take a child into protected custody
for screening and testing and an
instance of suspected or actual criminal
exposure to Controlled Substances this
is amending RSA
639-
aon1 that presently pertains only to
methamphetamine exposure to add add
exposure to Controlled Substances except
those possessed pursuant to a valid
prescription as defined by RSA
318-b
colon1 um oh my gosh I forget my Roman
numerals anyway I'm going to just say
XXVI so there you go into the human body
and to give you a little bit of a
background as to how the idea to amend
this bill came about I've been working
with the legislative youth advisory
Council for the past couple of years and
I received a phone call over the summer
from one of our members test sumers and
she wanted to talk to me about amending
this RSA and she along with Chief
suckling from Alexandria convinced me we
needed to do so and I wanted to
highlight for whomever is listening at
home especially if you're a young person
that no matter what age you are you can
affect positive change and your efforts
do make a difference I wanted to give
you a bit of mystory about 639- a colon
one for those who weren't in the
legislature at the time this law was
created and I wasn't either and it was
interesting to research it um our
current law pertains only to
methamphetamine exposure and this came
about as a result of the methamphetamine
crisis in the early 2000s the federal
drug endangered children movement began
then to respond to the growing
phenomenon of finding children living
among the squalor of meth labs located
in home homes and other areas where
children were living and playing and the
children found in these situations were
often severely harmed or neglected and
in many instances tested positive for
drugs and at that time Most states pass
laws nearly identical to
ours since that time many states have
expanded their drug exposed and child
endangerment laws and we need to do so
also during the past eight years there
have been six child deaths that have
been confirmed from accident Al drug
exposure and three of those had occurred
in 2022 and
2023 three deaths occurred from fentanyl
overdose one death from Fentanyl and
cocaine combined overdose and one death
from a combination of methamphetamine
and Fentanyl overdose regarding children
who have had serious medical incidents
from illegal drug exposure we are
reminded quite frequently from the
media of this crisis to that I would
like to note for you have occurred in
the past few months an 11-year-old and a
2-year-old both of them had to have
First Responders administer Naran to
them to save their
lives in speaking with Chief suckling
and my police chief chief fi and other
local and state law enforcement folks
they're looking for help to help
children they are seeing in situations
that can cause immediate harm or death
they want to be able to facilitate
immediate testing to a child they
suspect
sorry has ingested inhaled or absorbed
through the skin a drug or drugs that
can cause irreversible harm or
death give us the tools we need to help
these kids is what I'm constantly
hearing from law
enforcement the real goal here is to
enable the coordinated efforts of law
enforcement medical services and child
welfare services to ensure that drug
endangered children and their families
receive appropriate attention and care
after me you will hear testimony on what
these officers are experiencing boots on
the ground around the state with
children exposed to all sorts of illegal
drugs and the real life positive effects
of what passing this bill will mean
thanks for your time this afternoon and
I know you've had a long day again and
I'm going to keep it short here if you
them so I'm also up here because we also
put together an amendment we're hoping
you will consider we spoke to the
speaker and he has approved of this it
is to um extend the statute of
limitations for child endangerment to 10
years
so if if if I may I'm just looking at
I'm looking at obviously the bill that
you gave us not the not the amendment no
yeah
um so so basically where you have you
know crossed off the methan fetamines
related and added you just basically
changed out the that word for controll
drug controlled drugs or uh controlled
substance yes thank oh sorry yes thank
you for the question yes I did and I I
added as defined by that RSA in case
there would ever be any changes
additions or deletions from that um list
in that RSA that it would automatically
you know apply to this okay so basically
we wouldn't have to go back and
continuously change the law if it's if
the definition is changed to something
else or added right yes okay okay
representative Muse
as I read this this would include
cannabis as well correct yes it would
thank
you anybody else all right seeing no
much if if you could just give them to
um representative Newman she'll pass
Kirk thank you it's actually kerk my
more complicated name sorry about that
um so the K is not silent sorry the K is
not silent yeah and so actually this is
a great lead in representative Muse LED
right into this um I am the chair of sry
for the record Jerry kerk I am the chair
of the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board and a retired surgeon uh
the therapeutic Canabis medical
oversight border tcob is a is
statutorily charged with the medical
oversight of the New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis program it's
composed of 10 medical providers from
different Specialties and a therapeutic
cannabis patient the medical director of
a DHHS and a clinical representative
from an ATC atc's are the
dispensaries I must note that tcml did
not examine this bill as we were unaware
of it however my testimony is consistent
with the therapeutic cannabis statute
and the position of the department and
of TCM o regarding therapeutic cannabis
patient protections basically I'm a nerd
I was perusing the calendar I saw this
bill and I said huh does that have any
any impact on cannabis so I looked at it
and I realized it did the point is this
bill is well-intentioned and I'm simply
here to point out an oversight which can
be remedied with an
amendment uh as written it has
unintended consequences which will
impact patients and caregivers
registered with the therapeutic cannabis
program the bill refers to the state's
control Drug Act in RSA
318b which includes cannabis or
marijuana the chapter does not have a
general carveout for therapeutic
cannabis authorized under RSA
126x so in cases like this in which we
are referring to 318 broadly a specific
exemption is needed for those registered
patients and caregivers to not be
unintentionally impacted
it's it is important as representative M
pointed out that cannabis is included
because we know that kids are getting a
hold of parents cannabis and that is not
good and that's why we really care about
it in the therapeutic cannabis program
but the Department of Health and Human
Services position is that therapeutic
cannabis should be treated the same as
prescription medications HP 473 includes
the appropriate exception for someone to
have a controlled substance if they have
a prescription for it however the
therapeutic cannabis program does not
use a prescription for cannabis and the
reason for that is that cannabis is a
schedule one drug and therefore it
cannot be prescribed that's the
definition a person becomes a qualifying
patient when their provider certifies
that they have a qualifying condition
listed in statute which allows them to
possess and use therapeutic
cannabis now this exemption so we need
to put an exemption in for the
therapeutic cannabis patients because
they should be treated the same as if
they had a prescription but this
exemption would also need to include
caregivers not just patients and the
therapeutic cannabis program a caregiver
is somebody who handles cannabis for a
patient because of the patient's
inability to do so so for example let's
say you have an elderly person who
cannot drive is using therapeutic
cannabis for severe pain and the
caregiver is the one who drives to the
ATC CU there's you know there's only
seven around the state
and they will drive there pick it up for
that uh patient and bring it back but
they may actually have it in their house
for a short time before they make the
delivery to that
patient likewise miners are not allowed
to handle their own cannabis in the
program the parent or the legal guardian
is designated as a caregiver to handle
their cannabis so we wouldn't want the
child taken away because the parent gave
them the Cannabis that they're supposed
to be taking for their pediatric seizure
dis order when they are supposed to be
able to do that under RSA
126x now the department supports the
responsible use and storage of
therapeutic cannabis products our rules
require that uh uh cannabis is dispensed
in child resistant packaging opaque and
not attractive to kids their program
encourages and provides educa excuse me
education on safe storage and transport
and use of cannabis if there are
children in the home they sell atcs sell
lock boxes to keep it safe and the DH
DHHS has the authorization to revoke the
registration of a patient who uses quote
cannabis in a manner that puts others at
risk of their health safety or welfare
or who has failed to take reasonable
precautions to avoid putting others at
such risk end quote therefore I would
ask that an amendment be crafted to
clarify that this chapters does not
apply to patients or caregivers in the
therapeutic cannabis program that would
not preclude it still applying to
somebody who's using recreational
Cannabis only if they are a registered
patient or caregiver this could be most
easily achieved by adding a new section
five and I have this this language is in
the handout that I gave you of my
testimony that could State this chapter
shall not apply to the therapeutic use
of cannabis as authorized by oh it
should say RSA 126x my apologies the
wording would include that that wording
would include then both the qualifying
Pat and caregivers and Mike Hol who's
the therapeutic cannabis program
administrator and I will be happy to
assist in crafting the amendment if you
have any questions thank you and do you
point sorry I was trying to finish up
my okay
so so
basically I just want to make sure I
understand
is regardless if it was
therapeutic or just regular cannabis a
person having it that's not supposed to
in this situation would be a
minor is the same effect so what you're
saying is if they're supposed to have it
that's why you want the carve out yes I
mean basically it's um the language that
is currently in the bill very nicely
carves out saying hey I've got a
prescription for let's say per cassette
and so the fact I have it in my house
and there's a kid in the house doesn't
mean I'm abusing drugs because I got to
prescription but because cannabis is a
schedule one drug you cannot have a
prescription instead you're a qualified
patient it's just a bit of a you know
kind of sticky thing that it's it's it's
just the way the program has to work
because it's a schedule one drug if it
does get rescheduled the three which is
being talked about that would all change
but um so this would just allow the same
protections for a therapedic cannabis
program as a person who is using a
controlled substance under prescription
because again this is all under the
guidance of a provider
you don't get qualified just by you know
saying I want it your provider qualifies
you saying you have a qualifying
condition and therefore you uh gain the
protections of
126x and so it is still under the
direction of a provider understood thank
um representative pette do you have your
hand up no representative
Muse could you explain to me one more
time for the those who don't get it in
the back World which include me
um how DHHS and and the and the
therapeutic cannabis program just the
steps that are in place um for somebody
who does allow their cannabus to be used
let's say by kids even their own kids um
yes I mean first of all important to
understand there are only six minors who
are qualified we really try to avoid the
use of cannabis in anybody under age 25
because of the developing brain and
there are distinct problems however it
can be of help in some pediatric seizure
disorders uh which have failed standard
therapy it also uh we did approve it a
few years ago for autism spectrum
disorder because we do not have great uh
treatments for that and it can be
helpful in there at least there's some
modest evidence about that so there
first of all there are very few minors
and the point is for those few miners
they par or the legal guardian is their
caregiver they're the ones who hold it
keep it and give it to the kid to use
the kid doesn't just go grab his gummy
out of his thing it's not allowed um but
but again the bottom line is it's simply
the Cannabis is different because of
being schedule one therefore it's not
prescribed so what's in here is the
exception which was is is smart and a
good thing it just simply doesn't work
for the therapeutic cannabis patients
and I think that was just an oversight
um you know people most people don't
think about it think well therapeutic
cannabis patient they must have a
prescription for it no doesn't work that
way because the schedule one so just
this other language would make it work
and it would again would oh I should say
we have roughly about 15,000 patients so
there's not a huge number the great
majority are between ages 50 and 60 uh
pain is responsible for about 72% of
that's about 72% of the qualifying
conditions patients are there are using
it for pain so you know it's a lot of
people our age as all of us know who
have pain and but you know sometimes it
can be intractable and it's better than
using
opioids representative L
cells thank you for taking my
question I take a number of
prescriptions that have my name right on
the label as well as the prescription if
a person has therapeutic cannabis how is
that packaged okay it is in um opaque uh
it's an an opaque uh child resistant
Packaging it does have warning labels on
it the packaging it is labeled uh that's
say that's what makes the program strong
is that all therapeutic cannabis
products are tested for contaminants and
also for the cannaboid profile for the
concentration let's say of THC CBD or
other canabo and that is all labeled on
there so that you know who what what it
contains follow up
followup is the name of the patient as
well as the doctor or whoever whoever
decides that this person is eligible is
that also on the
label I may have to turn to Mr hold is
the name of the patient on the
label
yeah s if you if you could you're you're
welcome to um to join yes just make sure
you turn that in and when you sit down
if you could just identify yourself so
that we so we have that in our clerk
doesn't um not have your name I
understand thank you uh for the record
my name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services thank you for
the question uh to answer the specific
question uh all cannabis products uh are
labeled um they do they are not labeled
with the patient's name they are labeled
with the patient's registry
identification number um they are not
labeled with the certifying provider's
name
um but they are labeled with the
alternative treatment center the
dispensaries name and license number um
these Provisions are Provisions
established in in law um designed I
believe uh to protect patient and
provider privacy with regard to their
use of a controlled
you that was helpful inform information
actually thank you um anybody else have
any questions
okay all right well saying none thank
you both very much thank you and do feel
free to contact us to help with crafting
although I think if you put in the words
letters RSA and what if you put in
RSA I would recommend that you talk to
um most likely the sponsors unless
somebody else here I uh one of the
things that I always say at the end of
hearings if you hear anything about an
amendment I would suggest uh out to the
sponsors or somebody else because I know
that I certainly don't have time to do
them
so all right who else we got up here
summer thank you um hi my name is Tess
suner um I'm a senior at Newfound
Regional High School thank you
chairperson and honorable members of the
committee for letting me speak
um
I started this bill as my senior project
um I am an advocate for child welfare
and I'm also a member of the New
Hampshire legislative youth advisory
Council where I met representative
Nelson but more importantly I am here
today as someone who has witnessed
firsthand the devastating consequences
of substance abuse on Children and
Families through my senior project I
have spent months researching the impact
of opioid and methamphetamine abuse on
children and our Le legal systems
response that research along with my
personal experiences has led me to
testify in support of House Bill 473 a
necessary step in protecting our state's
most vulnerable residents our children
substance abuse particularly Fentanyl
and other illicit opioids is devastating
families across New Hampshire in 2022
alone our state saw 486 confirmed drug
overdose deaths
410 of them or 85% of those invol
involved fentanyl yet our current laws
do not reflect the reality of this
crisis nhsa 639 a-2 criminalizes
methamphetamine production and
possession around children but it fails
to include Fentanyl and other dangerous
opioids despite their overwhelming
presence in overdose fatalities this Gap
in the law puts children at unnecessary
risk we do not have to look far to see
the tragic consequences of this
oversight as you will hear after me and
now in August 2023 a toddler in London
Dairy died from fentanyl exposure in
September 2024 a 9-month-old in
Claremont overdosed and required Naran
the following month another 9-month-old
in Charlestown overdosed after being
exposed to drugs dropped on the floor
these are not isolated incidents they
are painful reminders that our current
protections are not enough children are
uniquely vulnerable to opioid exposure
even small amounts whether ingested
inhaled or absorbed from residue can
cause fatal overdoses specifically for
fentanyl my research showed that the tip
of pencil lead so that small little tip
that amount of fentanyl can kill a child
Beyond physical harm children living in
environments of substance abuse
experience severe neglect instability
and Trauma when parents are under the
influence supervision and Care suffer
leaving children in dangerous situations
House Bill 473 proposes a simple but
critical Amendment expanding the current
statute to include Controlled Substances
rather than limiting it to
methamphetamine this change aligns the
law with the realities of today's opioid
epidemic while ensuring that valid
prescriptions remain protected under RSA
B1 this bill is not about punishing
individuals with substance use disorders
it is about protecting the most V
vulnerable children who are often left
defenseless in dangerous environment
ments it also strengthens law
enforcement's ability to intervene in
cases of suspected exposure by allowing
officers to take a child into protective
custody for screening and testing we
provide a critical tool to ensure that
child receive medical attention and
necessary support
services this aligns with New
Hampshire's commitment to child welfare
while respecting due process and
parental rights it does not mandate
removal but establishes immediate
assessment of potential harm a necessary
safeguard in situations where a child's
health and safety may be at risk this is
not just a policy issue it is a moral
imperative we have the opportunity to
take action before more children suffer
the consequences of a preventable
tragedy every child in New Hampshire
deserves the right to grow up in a safe
and healthy environment I urge you to
support House Bill 473 and help us
create a safer New Hampshire for all
children thank you for your time and
thank you very much what a great senior
project thank you and you all should
have my slideshow the packet that I
handed out was the slideshow that I
presented for my senior
project yes that thank you well done
thank you representative
Muse I do have do have one question you
probably heard um former representative
kerk's testimony about therapeutic
cannabis was it was it your intention
that therapeutic canab this be within
the scope of this bill no my research
was only on opioids and the opioid
crisis um but working with rep Nelson is
when we decided to include that RSA but
that was not my sole intention of this
you anybody else all right seeing no
further questions thank you very much
Ling thank you very much the members of
the committee and Madame chair for the
day I'm going to just Wing this sideways
sorry I apologize
um whenever you're ready does this come
good I'm going to give you more than 3
minutes cuz I want you to stay in the
hot seat I'm sorry I'm just whing away
here I yeah I do actually think we do
have uh larger chairs in other committee
rooms may maybe I should bring one in
here to make you more comfortable one of
the wheelie ones would be great oh that
was it it was because of your
equipment
load okay anyway thank you for having me
all seriousness I know this is no
laughing matter thank you I appreciate
it you're making feel a little bit more
at ease because cuz this is quite an
emotional topic for me and um I've
watched this uh
firsthand uh you know we're at the cold
face and I've written a whole bunch of
stuff here and I'm going to probably
ignore most of it so I just want to talk
to you about the truth I've been in law
enforcement for 14 years um 12 of that
has been a chief of police in in the
town of Alexandria and prior to that I
was a chief of police in danur and then
during that I was a chief chief of
police in damry and
Alexandria um I spent 2 years as a
patrol officer before I came chief of
police and uh I was 42 when I when I
became a police officer so I had some
lived experience um before I put on the
badge and the gun and uh and I've kind
of been there and done that and I'm
really sympathetic to people that are in
treatment and because of that I I'm on
several consortiums in the state one
including the uh rural community uh
opioid Reduction Program it's a federal
uh Grant by HSA and uh I'm on a
Consortium in Lon in that I Pro promote
recovery um I'm the Ying to the Yang of
law enforcement if you will we we will
arrest people for drug infractions and
we will take them to Recovery in the
same day it's incredibly successful for
us and I teach about that at a
conference every year in DC about
integrating law enforcement to recovery
efforts it can work but this bill's so
important this bill's been around since
2006 and and I can only guess is that it
was introduced because of um the the
homecooked um methamphetamine back there
well that that's not happening as much
anymore because there's so much
methamphetamine in the state that's
coming in from
Mexico or Southern States I'm I'm not
going to elaborate on that that's
outside my skill set but I want to talk
to you about um also say that I support
this spell I think that's given and I'm
here actually representing New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association as well and
they support this bill um I want to talk
to you about a case that I was involved
in it was down in London Derry two
parents had decided one night two
parents and another adult had decided
one night that they they' take a
four-wheeler and take a trip down to
Massachusetts and swap that four-wheeler
for fenel um and they did they went down
to Massachusetts swapped this
fourwheeler picked up some fenyl and uh
they were from around our area around
the Lakes Region and they made it as far
back as London dery before they they
felt the use to the urge to use their um
fenel uh they used it they fell asleep
and their toddler ate it and that
toddler died and
uh and I spent quite a bit of time
working uh to find those people once
that case was presented to a grand jury
um and I worked with the US Marshals to
find several of those individuals around
the state um they're since serving long
long jail sentences but their family
will never be the same and and I'm sure
they regret it every single day um I
worked another case in in a small town
where we were um investigating this
house for the possession of
methamphetamine and I know that there
was two small children in that house and
they were going to a local school and as
part of being a community orientated
police officer I would go to the school
often and we see these kids asleep and
as part of our our case that we were
building on this house and the sales of
the methamphetamine out of that house um
I would watch the house uh you know it's
in my community it wasn't far I would
drive around at all hours of the night
and we would see this house was awake
all night and these kids were suffering
and and not just a little bit they were
suffering hard the schooling was their
escape and um they need to get out of
that house we we arrested um both
parties and got DC if there to help us
with the investigation and the
subsequent cleanup that the children
were taken they were tested um we never
found out the results of the test it
wasn't for us to find out it was more of
a DCF issue within a couple of weeks
those kids were back at school uh a
young male was talking conversing and
they were learning again and these kids
put on weight and they're doing great
ever since
um uh Tess uh talked earlier about a
9-month old that was reved during Naran
up in
Claremont the amount of feny that it
takes I know T talked to this the amount
of feny that it takes to kill a small
child is is nothing it's next to nothing
and yet this is a highly Airborne drug
that is easily ingested by by young
children I myself was was exposed to
fenyl uh a long time ago I'm not going
to age myself but it was one of the
first exposures to law enforcement uh in
the country the CDC came out and did a
whole bunch of testing on me I was fine
it was an exposure but it's significant
um we we want this bill to pass because
we want more Tools in our tool belt to
help the family this isn't necessarily
about prosecution but it comes as a law
so obviously there's consequences to
that but we want to help these kids cuz
our kids future isn't negotiable neither
is their safety so I welcome any
really no here's your chance I I I know
actually you did you did a very nice job
thank you very much I don't see any
question and also this isn't to negate
any kind of Fourth Amendment issues as
well this is about picking up the pieces
after the case is done I just want you
to I think that's an important note so
thank you very much for listening to my
testimony here today appreciate you all
yeah thank you for adding that thank you
very much else we got right is there
anybody else here wishing to testify on
House Bill 473 that has not turned in a
pink card seeing none I will close the
public
hearing and it is it is time I will open
the public hearing for house B
528 and welcome representative Ural to
legislation good afternoon Madam chair
members of the the the committee for the
record I'm representative Kevin verville
from Rockingham second district I
represent representative if you could
hold on one second just one second
there's a lot of ruckus behind you and I
don't want I don't want us not to be
able to hear you so we'll just give them
a second to clear out at at your
convenience I apologize for the
easy all right looks like you're good to
go thank you yeah thank you so again I'm
representative Uh Kevin verbel I
represent Rockingham second district uh
so I represent the cans of uh the cans
the towns of Auburn Candia and dear
field the words in the head go faster
than the words that come out of my mouth
so um you'll you'll hear funny things
every now and then so I apologize for
that
um the thing I want to start out
with is this bill is not about
amphetamines it's not about barbituates
it's not about narcotics it's not about
opioids right those are highly addictive
highly dangerous and potentially deadly
drugs and and they should be schedule
one drugs they should be very tightly
controlled what I've come to talk to you
about today is a psychedelics bill and
so we have to learn to compromise right
and so two years ago this bill uh came
before this commit actually can I back
up one second I want to apologize to the
committee you um had a sister Bill to to
this which was a a cannabis bill
basically the same language but cannabis
that was my bill and and I was not able
to introduce it I got called out of
state um on un unexpected business and
so I I couldn't be here so I I apologize
for not being here for that for that
that bill I just wanted to make sure
that that that got said so two years ago
I filed a a bill that uh wanted to uh
decriminalize at the state level um
several uh psychedelics um I search a
aciid damid LSD mesculin and peyote um
and cybin right so um those those were
the
three it it was it was a fun little
debate that we had both at the committee
level and at the floor of the house and
and I was really shocked because on the
floor of the
house on an itl bill I got 40% of the
votes that I needed to pass it and and
it's a pretty big bite at the Apple
right I'm you know I'm I'm smart enough
to know that uh going after all three is
is a big
bite and and I got a lot of feedback
from people that were sympathetic but
didn't vote in favor and and so what
I've what I've done this year is I've
rolled this back to only be psilocin
psilocybin is the active ingredient in
magic mushrooms right what they call
magic mushrooms psychedelic
mushrooms psychedelic mushrooms grow in
all 50 states they they grow on all
continents except for Antarctica so so
psychedelic mushrooms psilocybin
mushrooms are are quite ubiquitous
globally they've been used for uh
thousands and thousands of
years uh some people would say they they
are abused um and and I suppose at some
level uh they are subject to abuse one
thing we should know about soloc cybin
is there's um no effectively no ld50 so
an ld50 is a lethal dose that'll kill
50% of a given population so uh
typically they use a um kilogram rat
right a two pound rat and and and do it
by
that the only way to kill a a rat with
cocy and you'd have to have enough of it
to drop it on its head and crush it okay
the other thing that's interesting is
that you can't overdose on
psilocybin you can take a lot um you
know you can you can lose your your your
lucidness but you you can't take enough
psilocybin to to to kill yourself right
so that that's not a reality another
interesting thing about uh virtually all
psychedelics is they're they're not
habit forming and they're not prone to
um short cycle repetitive use right so
if you think about um the way
amphetamines barbituates Etc work um you
take the drug you get a high uh you come
down off the high you want to do it
again you have to take take a little bit
more cuzz your body built up a little
little bit of Tolerance and and so then
you're on that cycle right a little more
a little more a little more a little
more next thing you know it the drug
controls your life so if we all got
together and and obviously we wouldn't
do this because it's illegal but if we
all got together and and had a a
psychedelic mushroom Experience Saturday
night and some of you woke up Sunday
morning and said wow I really want to do
that again what you would find is if you
did the same dose or more you would not
get the same
effect and so if you said gez you know
that wasn't as good as the first time
I'm going to take twice as much you'll
actually get less of effect than you did
on on Sunday so the more often you do it
in a short amount of time the less the
effect it has so it's not it's not prone
to addictive behavior okay just very
important things that we we should know
about
this what this would do is it would
decriminalize
I psilocybin and psilocybin
containing fungus in the state of New
Hampshire it would not remove it from
schedule one which is a federal law and
so ferally it would remain
illegal and so what this does what this
bill is is harm
prevention most of the people that get
caught with psychedelics are young this
bill is 21 and over but they tend to be
younger in life and the conviction is a
felony and a felony conviction has
longlasting negative repercussions on a
person's life so if you accidentally got
caught with my psychedelics he couldn't
become a school teacher it'd be tough to
get a license to do that all all sorts
of different things so it it removes the
the felony
conviction and so some people would say
well then we're going to have mushrooms
rampant right two years ago the state
police Lieutenant um who's in charge of
uh the drug Division I forget exactly
what they call
it testified and he was asked you know
hey how many how many times do you
arrest people for psychedelics
possession and he couldn't he couldn't
remember the last time but his testimony
went on to say that he had a child in
high school and the child in high school
says they are readily available
everywhere so the pro prohibition
doesn't work right the the material is
is
available what I want to do is remove
the penalty the the felony penalty for
the for the possession and that's what
this bill does you say okay well now
it's going to run rampant right you can
imagine that somebody's now going to
mass-produced mushrooms in their in
their basement to sell um on what would
essentially be a legal Market in New
Hampshire Black Market in other states
but but that's not going to happen and
the reason that's not going to happen is
the feds aren't going to allow that
right the federal authorities are not
going to allow mass production of
psychedelic mushrooms so they're they're
not going to allow commercial sales so
if you say well all of a sudden you know
New Hampshire allows for for sale which
technically this bill would do if you
opened up a psychedelic mushroom shop I
guarantee you by the second day you open
your door uh there's going to be black
shiny shoes at your doorstep asking you
a lot of questions and probably asking
you to go with them right so so while
this bill seems Broad in scope it it
really isn't it's just trying to to
allow some some harm
prevention um for for New Hampshire
citizens I I dream of a day when we have
medical psychedelics available I dream
of that day I there
are demonstrated medical
benefits with um depression
post-traumatic stress
syndrome interestingly enough addiction
right so psychedelics can be used to
cure addiction to a very high rate and
and the most interesting part is right
if you're not familiar with this the way
psychedelic therapy works for
essentially all of these these different
issues is a single high does experience
with medical personnel right so you
counseling experience counseling and it
has a huge success rate we we are a long
ways from that right we're still we're
still arguing about medical cannabis in
the
state so in in lie of that I would
strongly encourage this
committee to vote this uh OTP so we can
have a debate on the floor of the
house let's at least have the open
debate people are are our constituents
are very open to this the polling
numbers keep going up if you're against
it you can still you can still give it
an OP OTP out of committee because when
it when it crosses to the other side of
the
wall or if by by some miracle of God it
it it escaped that other body uh it'll
it'll end up in a corner office where
you know it it doesn't have a lot of
future but I think I think it's a
discussion I think it's a debate that we
really need to to start having in an in
an honest forthright
Manner and so that's why I I bring this
bill to you thank you madam chair thank
you representative representative n
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um I have followed
your your um bills around um psychedelic
Therapeutics and things like that and um
I didn't see one this year and I'm
curious why um why you chose to go this
way instead of trying to push forward
the therapeutic um the therapeutic
psychedelics
bill thank you for the question so so
the representative has decided she's
going to blow my cover and I'll give you
I'll give am I yeah you are and I I'll
give you it's not a it's not a secret um
although I don't broadcast it it's a
two-year
session when this bill dies wherever it
dies because that's what's going to
happen to it right
eventually it can't come back next year
right so
similar language you could take a
different approach to it in the second
year but not the same
approach so if if there's a cake to be
had and you have two chances to eat the
cake it's always worth it's like a pie
eating contest right if I could eat the
pie in one bite that's preferable to um
having to nibble away at it this is this
is the Big
Bite
right I don't know that I will be
bringing a therapeutic Bill forward next
year uh but I am quite certain that
there are individuals that that will um
so you you will you will see that and I
think that's a worthy
Bill what I would beg this committee is
to not give this an itl
recommendation knowing fairly certainly
that there'll be um a therapeutic bill
if I can give you a more thorough answer
the the reason I say that is we are not
in alignment as to what therapeutic
psychedelic should look like so in the
1950s in the early 1960s when
psychedelics were perfectly legal
globally Nevada is actually the state
that began the clamp down California
went second and then the feds intervened
and they slammed it all shut all the
therapy all the research everything and
back then you had Hollywood stars going
to Boutique medical facilities getting
psychedelic
treatments and so if you're rich and you
access I don't like that model right I
I'm here for the little guy I'm I'm not
here for for for for elite hardto
penetrate
systems and I'm afraid that if we go
psychedelics therapy that that's
probably going to be the first nibble
that pass
and I think it's going to be very
difficult to open it up beyond that um
and and that that scares me that also so
now you have this legal venue right for
those that can afford it because the
insurance isn't going to cover it you're
gon to have to pay out of pocket right
Insurance isn't going to cover
psychedelic therapy in in New Hampshire
almost
certainly and so now you still got the
average Joe and average Jane subject to
penalty felony penalties I don't know
why I can't say that today
Fen felony penalty say that three times
fast um thank you for something that's
available to to to others that that can
afford the Buy in to me this is a better
better solution this is a better solu
it's still federally illegal and and I I
I will make the commitment that if this
bill passes by the grace of God and all
of a sudden we have a magic mushroom
problem in this state I will be the
first one to run back to this committee
and bring common sense
legislation to tighten it up to bring it
back under control but I already know
that psychedelics are readily available
in all 50 states at very competitive
prices on the black market so the
prohibition does is doing nothing and
the people that are getting caught are
not fentanyl addicts they're not cocaine
addicts they're they're not
methampetamine addicts um they're
they're there people that are either
looking to explore their inner self uh
or their their self-medicated for for
other reasons long long answer thank you
thank
Muse would it surprise you to know that
while I oppose outright
legalization I would be more than
willing to work with somebody on a
therapeutic bill because over the last
few years I've seen a huge amount of
research that indicates that this may
actually be a tremendously beneficial
form of therapy but the reality is is
that no therapeutic version of
psilocybin has been approved for human
consumption
yet I'm going to assume that's in the
form of a question thank
you so I I I thank I thank you for the
question so the the
FDA has not approved psychedelic therapy
for Broad band use it is only in the
last couple of decades that they have
allowed very limited very limited um
ability to to run trials to run clinical
trials and do research there is a huge
body of research from the 1950s and the
1960s publicly available right it's it's
it was all published in medical journals
the research that's being done today is
piggybacked on on on that work right
they're they're standing on the the
shoulders of giants in my opinion the
the FDA is is not likely to um Embrace
psychedelic therapy anytime soon mostly
because it's the federal um monolith
right that's very hard to crack so I I
think we're better off approaching it at
the state at the state
level I I understand I understand your
position I I'm still going to beg you to
to give me an OTP so we can at least
have um a nice floor debate to to start
getting people thinking about this a
little bit differently um I I guarantee
you um if there's a Therapeutics Bill
next year and there will be um I I will
be I will be working with people on that
um and what I would what I would ask is
that you remember my words of caution
that we don't set up a a system um that
allows the halves to have and and the
have knots to to be locked out of access
because that that was the major problem
with the the the clinical side in the in
60s I'm I'm pretty sure we're going to
need subs next week representative veral
if you're you know volunteering
I'm so I appreciate the offer
unfortunately um half of the management
team of the company I work for is is
traveling next week and so I'm clamped
down pretty
I don't see any further questions thank
you thank you very much thank you
appreciate the
pette hi guys I'm representative
Kathleen pette from Manchester and I'm
one of the uh the little guys that he
was referring to
earlier um today I'm going to share some
something with all of you that's deeply
personal to me uh it's a side of me I
don't share too often and usually only
with those that I'm closest to I want to
share with you the most intimate part of
my life my
pain um I may look fine on a day-to-day
basis and sometimes I am but often I'm
not I've often been told it can't be
that bad you look fine my unfortunate
reality is that I'm anything but fine
I'm just going to just pass this one
I suffer from a chronic excruciating
pain condition called trigeminal calgia
also known as cluster headache they're
called cluster headaches because they
tend to cycle and come in clusters when
I'm in cycle I have unbearable attacks
of burning piercing stabbing pain behind
my eye the pain is so violently severe
that I cry I rock I pace and I usually
end up rolling around on the the floor
clutching my head and sobbing my nose
runs my eye swells and it's not unusual
vomiting the attack of pain can last
anywhere between 10 minutes to 3
hours they can occur several times in
one
night just when I'm exhausted enough to
sleep it starts all over again this
often happens every night for months at
a
time there have been times where I
haven't had a good night's sleep for
year
sorry um I've personally broken multiple
bones gave birth to multiple babies
experienced kidney stones and had
several surgeries I have yet to
experience anything more painful than a
cluster
attack Tylenol Advil migraine meds don't
put the slightest dent in these attacks
IV pain medication such as morphine or
diloted don't even come close to
touching it my only tool for shortening
the duration of these attacks is high
flow oxygen using a special mask I have
an oxygen tank almost as tall as I am
besides my
bed cluster headaches are unfortunately
a well underdiagnosed condition because
it's just not so well known and it can
take up to 10 years to get a correct
diagnosis I unfortunately remember my
first cluster headache very well I was 5
years old I was finally correctly
diagnosed at the age of 38
I unfortunately don't remember a time in
my life when pain wasn't part of
it these are considered one of the most
painful disorders and are Al often
called suicide headaches because over
70% of people with my condition
contemplate ending it all suicide in my
population is over 20 times the national
average way too many of way too many
members of my cluster headache family
were unfort for no longer able to see
past the pain and they're no longer with
us those of you who follow me on social
media will notice that I sometimes
change my profile picture to a picture
of this
ribbon this means yet another friend
couldn't bear the pain of another
day the episodic nature the
unpredictability the unbearable pain and
the impact on every single aspect of
your life makes you feel desperate to
find an end to your suffering
when I was finally diagnosed I attended
an event and finally met someone who
suffered from my condition who got it
who understood me that day opened me up
to support and a family from all over
the world I'm sharing this with all of
you because that day I was given hope
that day I was educated about silos
cybin It is believed to help people like
me by potentially interrupting and
preventing headache Cycles it is thought
to reduce inflammation in the brain all
alter pain perception and reset the
neural Pathways that interrupts these
painful
Cycles very occasional use of small non
hucog enic micro does and at times even
a single dose has been known to increase
remission periods or even stop a cycle
completely in his
tracks as little as a single dose has
the power to allow someone relief when
there hasn't been any for years or even
decades
it has the power to give someone back
their ability to be present for their
family to give someone back their
dignity and most of all making silus
ibin available to someone like me has
the power to save lives I'm asking for
you to consider passing HB
528 um at least make an effort to try
some form of making it work because
people like me shouldn't have to make a
choice between living our lives and
breaking the law thank you all for
giving me the opportunity to share this
with you um um I
had um somebody from my family from my
cluster family was going to come here
today and testify but um they were
coming from Chicago and New Jersey and
opted not to so I have um I have a
testimony for you and I also have some
some additional information about
that sorry thank you
representative Representative no
gone I don't think she W representative
question representative
Newman yeah just that was a
very intense for you to do and for us to
hear wasn't easy and I was just curious
with since it's so successful you I just
curious how
long um the remissions might be and has
has how how well it has affected your
ability to do things just because you
take that thank
you um so there are a lot there there
are some people that just sort of use it
medically on a scheduled basis um but
for others uh one
dose um one dose
causes months and months of remission um
there's actually people that I know that
have been used it one time um they've
Olsen I have a similar story um I don't
I don't know that my condition is a a
cluster headache issue I I believe it
was um caused by exposure to an a common
food additive um so it's it's a little
bit different but a very similar sort of
feeling it would
um uh create a a blinding overwhelming
pain that essentially made me not
functional for 12 hours at a
time um
this happened frequently enough where it
would would have essentially prevented
me from being a functional human being I
it's hard for me to imagine how someone
uh experiencing that could maintain a
job or take care of their home or
anything like that
um I went through uh number of uh
attempts to figure this out and and to
deal with it I
uh I had an MRI at Mayo and was
prescribed rise of triptan which does
almost nothing um later I was given T it
all by a a local Clinic which also does
almost nothing these are expensive
medications um that they give you very
little of in a prescription and uh you
essentially would have to carry it with
you all the time because you don't know
when it's going to happen and they do
almost
nothing um I think it's important to
point out the uh the nature of the
randomness as well the initial symptom
of this migraine is uh that things
disappear in your field of vision um I
don't know if if anyone has experienced
seeing your blind spots um you can uh
there's little uh optical illusions you
can look up online that'll let you
experience this if you haven't but
essentially it's it's as if something
that normally would be right in your
field of vision like say one of you uh
was just photoshopped out of the
picture um so that being the the initial
symptom um is a pretty dangerous thing
um if you're not immediately aware of it
if you don't realize that there's
something there you know in the case of
say driving for example and once you
notice that initial symptom if you
notice that initial symptom uh you have
about 10 or 15 minutes to be somewhere
where you can be in capacitated for 12
hours um that's pretty problematic for
so I was aware that people had used
psilocybin for headaches um for
migraines and uh being in a situation
where essentially can't continue to to
live without doing something about it uh
I tried that uh thankfully I was able to
you know safely obtain that at the time
um which a lot of people are
unfortunately not able to do um and I
tried it and it immediately turned off
the migraine as soon as it happened I
tried that a couple of times and it
worked every
time now I'm in the position where well
what do I do do I for the rest of my
life carry around
a prohibited substance in case I get a
migraine that's a dangerous thing to
do
um so it's a it's a very awkward
situation to put a person in now
thankfully uh um I did come up with a
solution for this I I took uh a small
dose one of these micro doses uh 6 days
a week for a year and I never had
another migraine again that was about 6
seven years
ago um so for me that worked I I don't
know that that would work for anyone
else I was never diagnosed with a
specific condition but I do know other
people with uh with migraines who have
said they've had similar experiences
cancelling
them um I think it's also worth pointing
out that despite this being um a
prohibited substance which undoubtedly
makes it greatly uh more costly than it
would could otherwise be um a micro do
is very small um my one-year therapy was
essentially you know 30 bucks um split
into you know 300 plus doses it's like a
penny a dose
um much much cheaper than any than a
single pill of any of the other
medication that I could have received uh
much much cheaper than a doctor's
appointment to get the prescription for
any of that medication um this is an
extreme cheap extremely effective
therapy
um
there there should be no barrier to
anyone being able to get this and this
is an effective dose that is orders of
magnitude smaller than what someone
would need for a recreational dose um
there
is there really isn't any risk that I
um I'll answer any questions if anybody
has
any when you were when you were micro
doing were you effectively
self-medicating or were you doing this
under the supervision of a physician or
how did that work uh the Physicians
didn't even tell me about this and I saw
a number of them um all they wanted to
do was
prescribe these expensive and frankly
useless medications uh none of them
mentioned psychedelic at all uh I was
aware of them I was aware that they were
used for headaches and
um you know that's yeah no no medical
professional did or said anything and I
think that's a serious concern when you
talk about doing a medical only bill um
you
know nobody is well nobody's really
informing medical professionals about
some of them are aware but they're
they're hesitant to to talk about it
much less prescribe it
um I'm I would be concerned that if done
if you know if it relied on a doctor
prescribing it that it just wouldn't get
it
Newman yes thank you
on quite a few prescription medications
there'll be a notice on the prescription
label that um a cautionary um note on
there this prescription might cause
drowsiness and recommended not to use
heavy equipment or to consider not
driving for a period of time is there
anything like that that you're aware of
with a psychedelic
use well I that would depend on quantity
I mean recreational dose especially for
a person who hasn't experienced that
before yeah could you would not want to
go drive around um for the dose that I
did for this well below the perceptive
level there's no noticeable effect from
it whatsoever like my
oneyear
uh you know system where I took it every
six days we're talking about a tiny tiny
little amount that's basically one
recreational dose taken by one person
over an entire year
um
so yeah that that would not have any
effect
um and uh I mean honestly even a dose
that did have an effect would probably
be safer than the migraine for
driving
um not that I would recommend that but
you know that's you can't do anything
when you're having the
migraine you know and the other thing is
that um
you you know if you take something that
could cause a side effect you know what
that side effect is going to be
um if it just happens to you randomly
you really don't know what to expect or
when it's going to kick in um and that
that in itself is pretty
dangerous um you just don't know what
situation you're going to be in if if
something can randomly happen to you
that causes you to not be functional or
to not be able to see things that are
potentially important in your field of
you um how do you prepare for that you
basically would just have to think about
time see no further questions thank you
thanks is there anybody else here that
wishes to testify on House Bill 528 that
is not turned in a paint card saying
none I will close the public
hearing and
that concludes our business for the day
um thank you all very much a reminder we
have house session
tomorrow and we will meet back here uh
next Friday um Ways and Means has the